So, ich spiel mein Jingle ab. Das fetzt ja.
Total.
Ja. Wo kommt der jetzt her? Der Jingle?
Ich glaub von Stefan. War das der, den ich dir vorhin weitergeleitet habe auf deiner?
Der war das.
Ich befinde mich zurzeit nämlich in so einem kleinen Loch, in dem ich, weil ich so mit Arbeit zu bin, dass ich nichts mit meinem Warennehme gerade.
Das Problem ist, dass du Urlaub gemacht hast.
Das Problem ist, dass ich Urlaub gemacht habe? Das wäre die Lösung, jetzt noch drei Wochen Urlaub zu machen.
Echt?
Dein Stack-Buffer ist voll.
Mein Stack ist voll. Genau. Meine To-Do-Liste ist gefüllt und...
Du bist unkonzentriert einfach. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben wir diesen Jingle zugeschickt bekommen. Und ja, keine Ahnung. Das war ja ein Remix von diesem Pfeil, mit dem ich mal den Feed getestet habe. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht? Dieser schöne Kommentar von Steve Jobs, der meinte, der diese Geschichte erzählte, dass ja... Wer war es? National Geographic? Keine Ahnung. Irgendso eine Postille, was eine Liste aufgemacht hat. Welche Tiere sich denn am effizientesten fortbewegen würden? Also im Sinne von Verhältnis Kraftaufwand zu Raumgewinn. Und Platz 1 war der Condor. Naja, ich meine so große Schwingen und Fliegen und so.
Der lässt sich ja so lang schweben.
Naja, der schlägt nicht viel mit den Flügeln. Der macht einfach einmal so flabb.
Der macht nicht viel Wind.
Der macht einmal so flabb und ab geht er, Peter. Ja, und der Mensch war seiner Aussage nach... Also Steve Jobs berichtete das ja.
Jetzt weiß ich, was kommt. Es kommt das mit den Tools, richtig? Ja, der Mensch ist eigentlich ziemlich weit hinten in diesem Vergleich in der Natur. Aber der Mensch hat halt Tools, nämlich ein Fahrrad, so wie Apple halt Tools baut.
Das war der Computer is to me, sagt er.
Das war doch der Codename von Mac eine Zeit lang. Bicycle. Das war doch nicht der Codename, sondern es war eine Zeit lang überlegt worden, ob das Ding Bicycle heißen soll. Und es gibt auch noch so eine hübsche Zeichnung von so einem Fahrradfahrer, der hinten Mac auf dem Gepäckträger drauf hat. So einen der ersten. Und das war noch aus der Zeit, als wir noch überlegt haben, ob das Ding Bicycle heißt.
In der Wikipedia würden sie jetzt schreiben, dass so mit den Quabellen liefern soll, sonst wird deine Artikel gelöscht.
Das schreiben die dann nicht nur bei der Wikipedia. Das findet sich auch bei den Kommentaren im Post zu dieser Sendung auf MobileMacs sicherlich auch. Und genau, da sind wir. Hallo, MobileMacs Ausgabenummer 007. Geheimagentensendung. Richtig. Ey Leute, ich versuche hier gerade total coole James Bond Stimmung aufkommen zu lassen.
Ach, James Bond Stimmung.
Und klappert einfach dazwischen.
Das ist bei James Bond immer so.
Naja, das ist MM007.
Mir fehlen die hübschen Frauen ein bisschen.
Echt? Ursula kommt erst, nicht, dass sie dann Urlaub machen soll.
Genau.
Also Max ist wieder da, hallo Max, erstmal begrüßen.
Hallo.
Und zur linken, Dennis.
Ja, ich bin wie immer links.
Hallo, du bist wie immer links und ich bin wie immer in der Mitte.
Und bin ich auch wirklich aufgenommen?
Letztes Mal war ich rechts. Du bist aufgenommen. Das kannst du daran feststellen, dass du dich jetzt selber hörst. In diesem Setup, was ich gerade habe, ist es sozusagen gesichert. Also entweder werden wir alle aufgenommen oder keiner. Ich weiß schon, ich stehe tief in deiner Schuld. Na ja, wie auch immer. Und ich bin Tim. Hab ich mich schon vorgestellt? Nein, hab ich nicht. Und wir reden mal wieder. Nach zwei Wochen, nachdem wir die WWDC-Ergebnisse verdaut haben, bzw. Dennis und ich haben sie vorgekaut, wird es noch keine Gelegenheit, die zu verdauen, oder?
Ich hatte noch keine wirkliche Gelegenheit.
Dann bist du ja nicht wieder da.
Ich bin seit, ich bin schon eineinhalb Wochen wieder da, aber ich hab seitdem wirklich, also ich war nur eine Woche weg. Eine Woche in Mallorca, sehr, sehr schön, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Okay, d.h. du weißt eigentlich noch überhaupt nicht, was passiert ist. Hat es dir schon jemand erzählt?
Ich habe die Augen zugemacht, ich habe keinen Fan-Frauser geöffnet. Nee, also ich habe, ich weiß grob, was passiert ist, aber ich hatte tatsächlich nicht die Zeit, mich irgendwie tiefer in irgendwas reinzuarbeiten.
Also ich weiß, es gibt... Bist du glücklich?
Mit der Zeit nicht gehabt zu haben?
Nein, mit dem Ergebnis der WWDC.
Es gibt endlich ein neues iPhone, aber ansonsten, also das war ja eigentlich irgendwie ein Stück weit fällig.
Nicht für dich, aber...
Not for me, das habe ich auch schon gehört, dass es da möglicherweise, dass das ganz, ganz furchtbar kompliziert wird alles mit, nicht über T-Mobile und so. Wobei, irgendeine Möglichkeit wird es da wohl hoffentlich geben.
Da noch ist nichts abzusehen.
Das ist unklar, nicht? Also es sieht nach wie vor so aus, als ob die Aktivierung im Store erfolgt und das bedeutet, dass wenn man sein Telefon mit einem anderen Vertrag fahren will, dass man a.) dann mindestens zwei Verträge hat und b.) gibt es natürlich jetzt auch noch keine berichtete Hackerei, oder? Gibt es dann 2.0 schon irgendwelche Hacks?
Ach so, ja doch, doch. Das hacken die alles auf. Das ist wohl nicht das Problem. Also dieser Pornich-Hack ist unwiderbringlich, weil die den Bootloader gehackt haben. Der Bootloader checkt die Signatur und weil der Bootloader die Signatur jetzt nicht mehr checkt, können die da einspielen, was sie wollen.
Ja gut, aber dann müssen sie ja trotzdem noch Simlog deaktivieren und so weiter.
Ja, aber das ist wohl alles so wie vorher. Also die letzte Firma, die so rumfliegt, ist ja die Beta 7. Und da kann man bei der Pornich-Seite auch schon sehen, die kann man genauso hacken, wie alle Versionen von davor auch. Ist halt nur, dass die ihr Tool nicht erneuen, weil sie wahrscheinlich die Beta-Versionen gar nicht unterstützen wollen, sondern die kommen dann ganz fertig, damit wenn die finale Version rauskommt.
Na dann starten wir doch mal mit dem iPhone, auch wenn sich hier in den Kommentaren schon jemand beklagt hat, warum wir denn so viel über das iPhone reden, wo wir doch irgendwie den Mac im Titel tragen. Naja.
Wieso?
Das ist ja... Das ist der mobile Mac. So sehe ich das auch. Weil Mac-Giger geht es ja einfach schon fast gar nicht mehr.
Es läuft ja ein Mac oder ist es drauf?
Es läuft ein OS X.
Genau. Ist es jetzt umgebendert?
Also wir haben darüber gesprochen, aber es heißt, auf der Developer-Konferenz haben sie sich extrem bemüht, OS X zu sagen. Aber schon auf der Webseite für die nächste Version Snow Leopard steht auch Mac OS X. Also ich glaube, der Name ist noch nicht so tot, wie manche das geglaubt haben. Spielt aber auch am Ende gar keine Rolle. Ja, was habe ich denn gelesen? Also erstmal, es gibt Tarife von der Telekom, die gab es ja letztes Mal noch nicht.
Die sehen ziemlich exakt so aus, wie die alten Tarife.
Ich glaube, da hat sich nicht so sehr viel getan. Ich habe sie jetzt nicht so Punkt für Punkt verglichen. Allerdings gibt es ein Novum, was schon mal einen Kritikpunkt, den ich hatte, killt. Denn man kann jetzt mit der Karte auch eine Multisim bekommen. Das heißt, man kann sich noch eine zweite SIM-Karte besorgen und kann die dann für den Laptop benutzen auf demselben Datenflat und surfen. Was ich ganz gut finde, was auch dieses Problem behebt, dass das iPhone halt selber nicht als Boden agieren kann.
Gestern meinte er zu mir, er holt sich ja dann das neue iPhone und dann ist ja flat und will das auch mit seinem Laptop benutzen. Dann meinte ich, das geht nicht. Dann meinte er doch, da hat er ganz sicher gehört, dass es irgendwie gehen würde. Dann meinte ich, ich habe hier noch nichts von gehört. Und dann meinte er auch dieses Multisim-Zeugs.
Genau, wobei das immer noch nicht das Problem löst, dass man ja nur noch ein Gerät dafür braucht, weil du mit einer zweiten SIM-Karte bisher alleine noch nicht gesurft bist. Ich hatte das Problem ja auch, da wollte ich letztes Mal nicht schon drüber sprechen. Ich hab mir so auf Ebay so eine Huawei E220, Bluetooth, blödsinn, USB, SIM-Kartendongel geschoppt. Kennt ihr das Teil? Das haben eigentlich alle.
Das ist so ein kleines weißes Ding, das man so wie eine Maus hier außen dran hängt und dann ist da ein HSDP-A-Modem drinne.
Genau, das ist so ein kleines Ei.
Das hat auch gar nicht die Welt gekostet, wenn ich mich das recht mache.
Flach und oval, na ich hab's jetzt so für 100 Euro geschoppt. Kann man sicherlich auch noch billiger bekommen. Kriss hat halt teilweise mit Verträgen, Kriss ist halt nachgeschmissen mittlerweile, das kostet natürlich nichts, ist ja auch nicht viel drin. Hat allerdings einen Haken. Also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man das Ding zum Laufen bekommen kann. Das eine ist, dass man halt dieses Launch-Tunett nimmt hier von dieser Berliner Bude, wie heißt sie noch gleich? Nova Media. Genau. Na ja, mit diesem Tool, das funktioniert zwar. Also ich hab's jetzt konkret mit diesem Ding nicht ausprobiert, aber das Huawei gehört halt zu diesen unterstützten Geräten, weil das ist jetzt eh das verbreitetste Teil. Und die haben da halt die ganze Expertise reingeschmissen. Das ist ja im Wesentlichen auch die Arbeit, die man mit diesem Launch-Tunett, heißt das, ne? Was man da sozusagen für bezahlt, dass die sich eben den Krampf machen und diese ganzen Spezifika, diese einzelnen Devices erforschen und dann implementieren. Aber man hat halt so ein Programm, was alle möglichen Geräte unterstützt und letztes Mal, als ich es mir angeschaut habe, stört mich halt so ein paar Sachen. Das Ding hat mir so ein bisschen zu viel CPU gefressen und es war so ein bisschen unklar, wie sich das in die Networking-Architektur überhaupt mit einklingt und so.
Also es ist nicht das allerhübschste, was man sich vorstellen kann, aber es funktioniert. Also ich hab bisher noch nichts erlebt, was man nicht draufschmeißen konnte, womit es nicht gelaufen ist.
Das ist richtig. Also das kann ich zumindest, soweit ich es ausprobiert habe, bestätigen. Ich hab jetzt auch nicht sehr viel...
Ich hab mit PC-Cards, die mit der Original Vodafone-Software nicht zusammenarbeiten wollten, obwohl das eigentlich auch noch ein Launchnet sein müsste.
Ich mag einfach Software nicht, die irgendwo in meinem Betriebssystem irgendwelche Dinge aktiviert und mir ist nicht genau klar, welche. Also gerade so mein Networking-Setup ist mir extrem heilig. Da will ich einfach wissen, welche Einträge ich da drin habe und in welcher Reihenfolge die sind, weil ich eben verschiedene Arten und Weisen nutze, wie ich ins Netz gehe. Ich hab dann mal einen VPN-Tunnel, der da noch irgendwie drüber liegt und ich mach über Bluetooth mal mein Netz und so weiter und so fort. Naja, wie auch immer. Ist auf jeden Fall schneller als mit meinem Nokia E61. Das heißt, ich krieg hier, ich mach das ja mit O2, krieg da HSDPA raus, da rauschen dann schon mal so 400 Kilobyte pro Sekunde dran.
Ich hab das mal miterleben dürfen. Das war sehr, sehr beeindruckend, wie da ein Podcast drüber ging. Das war beeindruckend.
Ja, das ist richtig ordentliches Internet. Also zumindest was den Download betrifft, was den Upload betrifft, das ist eher lame.
Wundert mich aber immer noch, warum sie nicht irgendwie das iPhone, also das UMT-Sperre-Bluetooth irgendwie freigeben für den Rechner und man sich irgendwie noch extra hart verkaufen muss.
Können wir gleich darüber reden. Ich wollte noch kurz diesen Huawei-Part zu Ende bringen. Da ich also Launch-Tournette nicht benutzen wollte, habe ich gefahren nach einem Macintosh-Treiber, denn es gibt die. Vodafone verkauft diese Teile auch bei T-Mobile. Das Gerät ist auch im Angebot und du kannst es mit Verträgen und so weiter bekommen. Du bekommst auch die Treiber-Software dafür. Aber die Treiber-Software ist von Huawei selbst so nicht zum Download verfügbar. Sondern eben nur dieser ganze Windows-Klimp-Patch, der hier im Übrigen dann auch auf so einer absurden USB-Disk quasi sich mitmountet und so weiter. Wenn du bootest und das Teil ist dran, dann kommt er erstmal hoch und sagt hier ist was, was ich nicht lesen kann, ignore, eject und so. Also Unschönheiten, nichts wirklich Kritisches. Aber wenn man halt so im Netz ein bisschen verhandelt, findet man 2.6 oder Version 2.7 Treiber, die so irgendwie funktionieren. Also hast du so eine App und dann kannst du die PIN eingeben, das ist ja das eine Problem. Für uns natürlich keine Keychain. Wozu auch. Das sieht auch alles wieder nicht so aus, als hätten da erfahrende Macintosh-Programmierer was gemacht, sondern es ist immer alles so ein bisschen so My First. Weißt schon, My First Application.
Hey, ich hab ja sowas damit, kann man auch für ein Mac kompilieren.
Aber immerhin, ich hab das dann als Device in meiner Netzwerkgeschichte und kann halt sagen, hier connect und wenn das Ding also seine PIN gesehen hat und sich richtig einbucht, dann geht's. Manchmal bucht sich das Teil komischerweise mit einer O2-Karte auch bei Vodafone ein, dann krieg ich irgendwie kein Internet her. Also die Software erlaubt mir nicht, jetzt ein Netz zu forsen zum Beispiel. Das ist alles ein bisschen unklar. Also die ganze UMTS-Experience finde ich auf dem Macintosh eigentlich noch ganz schön scheiße. Und ich finde Apple sollte sich da mal ein bisschen am Kragen reißen, weil, mal ehrlich, ich meine jetzt bauen sie, sie haben die Expertise. Wo ist der USB-Dongel für SIM-Karte?
Man soll Apple selber rausbringen, so wie sie halt auch ihr Modem jetzt per USB machen.
Ja, oder was wir letztes Mal schon besprochen haben, wo ist der SIM-Karten-Slot in diesem Computer?
Das ist wirklich ein bisschen schade, dass wir das nicht haben.
Ich meine, wenn sie das im iPhone machen, warum machen sie das nicht auch im Mac?
Es gibt ja schon diverse billigste Rechner, die alle selbstverständlich ein HSDP-A-Modem eingebaut haben, oder ein UMTS-Modem zumindest. Und warum eigentlich, wieso diese zweieinhalbtausend-Euro-Kiste hier vorne nicht?
Früher hab ich es verstanden, dass sie das nicht machen, weil es einfach viel zu viele Standards gab, und es ist zwar wirklich langlebig, aber jetzt haben sie sich ja eingeschossen auf 3G. Und ich finde, sie könnten das nächste MacBook...
Naja, 3,5G mittlerweile, ja. 3,5.
Na gut, aber das sind ja alles Erweiterungen von UMTS. Also im Prinzip geht's jetzt auf UMTS, und meiner Meinung nach können sie das nächste MacBook Pro mit UMTS rausbringen. Meiner Meinung nach können sie das MacBook damit rausbringen.
Bitte?
Ja, vor allem mal eins, was den Namen Neu auch verdient.
Ja, weil das ist jetzt ja auch schon seit wieviel Jahren am Start?
Also dieses Gehäuse, das ist der zweite, den ich mit dem Gehäuse habe. Und das war schon nicht nur, als ich den ersten damit hatte.
Und das war auch mal ein Powerbook. Ja, ich mag ja, hab ich mich glaube ich schon ein paar Mal zugeäußert, also der Formfaktor vom MacBook Pro, kannst du mich mit jagen mittlerweile.
Ja, gut, ich find's eigentlich genau richtig, aber es müsste mal...
Ich finde, man kann einfach viel zu viele wichtige Dinge damit nicht tun.
Also ich hatte Urlaub, da hatte ich ja meinen kleinen lustigen IEI dabei, den ihr jetzt alle so furchtbar hasst. Für den Urlaub war das sehr grandios und es war schick, so einen wirklich extrem kleinen Rechner dabei zu haben, den man auch am Strand, also ich meine, der erstens nichts gekostet hat, und sofern eigentlich relativ wurscht ist, aber den man auch mal am Strand mitnehmen konnte oder sowas. Weil dafür ist so ein MacBook Pro oder so ein MacBook einfach zu groß, zu schwer, zu weiß der Teufel was. Und sowas in der Richtung, das wär schon eigentlich...
Wenn du jetzt einen Air dabei gehabt hättest?
Das wär mir zu teuer gewesen.
Ja gut, aber davon mal abgesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit einem Air gewesen wäre. Also ich hab den IEE runtergeschmissen, als ich sehr, sehr betrunken war. Das hätte ich mit dem MacBook eher nicht unbedingt machen wollen. Und... Tja, keine Ahnung. Also ich würde... Also ich fand den auch den kleinen Formfaktor sehr angenehm. Das ist ein bisschen kaum größer als ein Taschenbuch.
Aber dafür hat es halt keine Anwendung auf dem Ding, sondern nur Webbrowser.
Na ja, Webbrowser, Mail, Fotoprogramm, Videoplayer. Also man kann schon relativ viel machen unter Linux. Oder eigentlich alles sogar.
Man könnte einen VNC-Client starten und dann einfach auf seinem Heimcomputer arbeiten. Das wär vielleicht ganz cool.
Wenn das Netzwerk schnell genug wäre.
Wenn das Netzwerk schnell genug wäre. Das war nicht so schnell, ne? Wie sieht es denn aus auf Mallorca mit Internet?
Also in Zukunft wird man Touristen daran erkennen, dass sie nicht mit einer Kamera rumrennen, sondern mit ihrem kleinen iPhone auf der Suche nach WLAN.
War es so?
Also bei mir zumindest ja. Ich war die ganze Zeit unterwegs.
Du bist so rumgelaufen.
Ich bin so rumgelaufen.
Okay, aber sonst keiner. Die anderen haben sich alle nur gefragt, was geht denn hier?
Es gibt die Verbreitung mit WLAN. Ist genauso hoch wie hier, würde ich mal sagen. Also es gibt auch die Cafés mit WLAN.
Jeder Kanal ist zehnmal belegt.
Jeder Kanal ist zehnmal belegt. Man findet auch eine Handvoll freier Netzwerke, die dann aber meistens offensichtlich nicht konnektiert sind oder so was, über die man nicht ins Netz kommt. Das hab ich genau einmal geschafft. Also das ist, das geht schon alles. Das ist bloß...
Ok, können wir wieder zurückkommen zu den Tarifen? Also du hast ja gerade noch gesagt, Dennis, warum denn das iPhone...
Für uns nicht...
Warum es kein Bluetooth-Modem macht? Ja, naja.
Wäre nicht eher ein WLAN-Modem angesagt? Also das ist ein kleiner WLAN, das einen Schlusspunkt hat?
Ja, das ist...
Wäre auch, wie ist mir ja egal. So wie es halt am günstigsten oder beides halt, je nachdem, was weniger Strom verbraucht. Aber sie bieten es ja gar nicht an.
Sie bieten es nicht an, weil das iPhone natürlich auch dadurch besticht, dass es einfach Dinge nicht tut. Das ist aber Teil des Designs, ist erstmal das Wichtige zu implementieren. Und ich glaube, das haben sie einfach nicht als wichtig angesehen.
Also das ist sehr, sehr weit auf der Liste verwendet.
Ich denke, eine Sache ist, weil die Provider, die wollen halt flat anbieten, aber die wollen nicht, dass du es irgendwie überstrapazierst. Mit dem Rechner würde man halt den ganzen Tag irgendwie so ein Netz benutzen. Ich glaube, das wollen die nicht. Aber es ist natürlich...
Aber genau, das macht ja die Telekom jetzt.
Dem widersprechen tut halt diese Doppelsim, oder wie heißt es, Multisim. Und gut, aber vielleicht gibt es die wiederum nicht in allen Ländern.
Genau, das ist ja reine Vertragsgestaltung.
Die ist nicht das Problem.
Nee, aber das ist Vertragsgestaltung.
Also USA gibt's meines Wissens das nicht. Aber hier ist ja mittlerweile Surferei über UMTS halt ein richtiges Ding. Ich meine, UMTS ist neu in den USA. Das ist etwas, was nicht sehr ausgebaut ist. Und überhaupt sind die infrastrukturell, was Mobilfunknetze betrifft, digitale, nicht so weit wie Europa.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ist. Das iPhone 2, kann das noch Edge?
Klar, der schaltet ja runter. So kann es dann auch noch geben.
Sonst hätte das Ding kein Internet mehr in 90% des gebietesten USA.
Also das war nur eine Frage.
Nee, Edge hat's noch.
Gut.
Ja, ich meine, da gab's ja wenig Anlass, das rauszuschmeißen. Du kannst ja auch das 3G ausschalten.
Ah, okay.
Also du kannst auch sagen, ich will nicht schnell surfen. Ich will lieber Strom haben. Weil, hält halt doppelt so lang. Was ich ziemlich erstaunlich finde noch.
Was ich übrigens eine interessante Sache finde beim neuen iPhone. Achso, wir waren gerade bei den Tarifen, oder?
Wir waren bei den Tarifen und es gibt noch was Neues bei T-Mobile. Nämlich dürfen auch Fachhändler verkaufen.
Wie Gravis zum Beispiel.
Gravis ist jetzt wohl dann doch endlich im Boot. Das hab ich gestern auch probiert. Und ich schätze mal, dass sie halt auch mit, dürften sich wahrscheinlich einige ihrer Fachhändlerpartner beschwert haben, dass das alles nur exklusiv in den Stores von T-Mobile selber läuft.
Ich glaub eher, dass die Telekom-Versweifel-Läden sucht, die es auch verkaufen, weil niemand einfach so in einen Telekom-Laden rennt. Also die, die es haben wollen, rennen natürlich in einen Telekom-Laden. Aber so die Leute, die halt so schwanken, die rennen nicht unbedingt in einen Telekom-Laden und da wollen die, glaub ich, eine größere Verbreitung von, wie sagt man, Positionsflächen oder weiß schon hier, so Marketingflächen haben.
Du wirst natürlich mehr Frontallinien mit deinem Kunden haben.
Genau, das hat halt die Telekom nicht so doll viel. Ich glaub, das ist auch Ausrichtung der Telekom.
Na die haben schon extrem viele Stores, aber mehr kann halt nicht schaden, es sei denn, es ist für dich logistisch schwierig. Immerhin war beim iPhone ja die ganze Aktivierungsgeschichte was Besonderes. Das musste sich erstmal bewähren. Weißt du da geier, welche Auflagen es da gab? Ich schätze mal auch Apple dürfte da auf eine bestimmte Grundschulung der Mitarbeiter hingewirkt haben, dass da nicht einfach irgendwelche Elsen rumstehen, die jetzt wieder mal von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung haben. Und so iPhone, ach so, das ist ein Telefon, das wusste ich jetzt gar nicht. Petra, hast du da die Schulung gemacht mit diesem Phon?
Aber jetzt nochmal auf die Aktivierung zurückzukommen. Es wird jetzt auch in Amerika so sein, dass ich nicht einfach in den Laden gehen kann und mit dem iPhone wieder rausgehen kann, so wie das bisher ist, mit dem alten iPhone, ohne einen Vertrag unterschrieben zu haben. Sondern ich muss...
Einen 2-Jahres-Vertrag nehmen. Oder deinen alten Vertrag um 2 Jahre verlängern, und dann kriegst du auf den billigen ein neues iPhone.
So was.
Auf jeden Fall kriegst du ab dem Augenblick, dein Vertrag neu machst, auch wieder die 2 Jahre rangehangen.
Also was ich bisher gehört habe, ist, dass es nicht mehr über einen Web-Shop vertrieben wird und so was. Also dass man es nur noch direkt im Store bekommt.
Das kommt dazu.
Was natürlich für diesen neuen Vertriebsweg spricht. Haben Sie es explizit so gesagt? Oder ist das jetzt Gerüchtekirche?
Da gab es so eine interne Mail, die an die AT&T, wie sagt man, Vertriebschefs irgendwie geschickt wurde, von jeder einzelnen Niederlassung. Und da stand drin, wie sie genau das alles handhaben müssen. Also ziemlich exakt, auch wenn Leute schon eins haben und was dann alles so verschrieben eingeleitet werden müssen. Ja, damit wird der Grau-Importe-Markt oder der Graumarkt für das iPhone natürlich...
Auf andere Länder von der Gart.
Ja, aber welche?
Na es gibt doch einige, wo es wahrscheinlich ein Prepaid-Karten geben wird.
Ja, aber die kosten dann auch dementsprechend.
Ja, aber ich meine, das werden wir sehen.
Also wie in Frankreich für 750 Euro.
500 Euro habe ich jetzt gehört. 500 Euro in Italien.
500 Euro in Italien, mal sehen, was es in Frankreich kosten wird. In Großbritannien wird es glaube ich auch bei O2 eine Prepaid-Option geben.
Wird es ein iPhone ohne Vertrag für 500 Euro kaufen?
Da würde ich schon drüber nachdenken. Wenn es ge-unlockt ist. Das zahlt sich bei meinem Vertragsvorteil relativ zügig aus. Also die Kohle habe ich schnell wieder drin.
Wenn ich hier mein O2 mit irgendwie für diesen 10 Euro Angebot mit 200 Megabyte Daten, wie heißt das, Daten nicht rate, sondern 200 MB habe zum runterladen, ist das dann auch mit UMTS oder ist das nur mit GPS? Das müsste auch UMTS sein, oder?
Also es gibt jetzt von irgendwie seit dreieinhalb Tagen.
Du redest jetzt von dem Telekom-Tarif? Nein, O2-Tarif, ich hab bei O2. In England, in Britannien?
Nein, jetzt mein Telefon. Ich jetzt hab so einen Standard-O2-Tarif und jetzt hab ich doch für das iPhone extra mir so für 10 Euro extra 200 MB pro Monat aktiviert. Ob das auch mit UMTS dann gehen würde.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das auch mit UMTS geht.
Ich denke auch, die unterscheiden da nicht groß, weil die Telefone buchen sich einfach mal fleißig irgendwo ein und das noch zu unterscheiden, das würde sie wahrscheinlich komplett fertig machen. Nee, nee, das ist auch problematisch.
Aber es gibt ja auch, wenn wir da zu den Tarifen zurückkommen, von der Telekom in Deutschland den 29 Euro-Tarif. Der hat halt nicht mehr flat die Daten, sondern nur noch 500 MB, was ja auch schon gar nicht so wenig ist. Weil ich hab mal geguckt, ich verbrauche mit dem iPhone gar nicht so viel.
Nein, noch nicht, weil du nur GPS hast. Ich meine, wenn du den GPS hast, dann wird das bestimmt schnell mehr.
Viel kann es auch nicht sein, da ich jetzt den ganzen Tag meinen Telefon benutze. Ich hab ja immer noch meinen Laptop.
Ja, also dieser Billigtarif, der geht ja gar nicht.
Ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich okay, was mich ernernt, sind immer die zwei Jahre, ich mag nicht festkommen.
Na was ist denn, wenn du wirklich über die 500 MB hinauskommst?
Glaub ich nicht.
Na, wenn du da eine Multisim hast und mit deinem Rechner noch ein bisschen hinterher surfst.
Na dann, wenn es denn so viel benutzt, dann kannst du auch einen anderen Vertrag nehmen.
500 MB sind 500 Webseiten.
Na, kommt doch auf die Webseiten an.
Ja, im Schnitt.
Megabyte pro Webseite? Aber hallo.
Lad mal was runter heutzutage im Internet.
Kommt mal weiter, ich check mal wieviel die Spiegel-Hauptseite kostet.
Die Spiegel-Hauptseite ist keine 100 MB.
Die ist definitiv. Also ich hab mal Tests gemacht und ich hatte irgendwie so 500 Kilo-Byte bis 1 Megabyte pro Page heutzutage. Da wird tonnenweise Zeug runtergeladen. Dann Bilder und das Lädt alles hin und her.
Also die Spiegel-Seite komme ich hier auf 400 Kilo-Byte.
Wie misst du das gerade?
Ich hab halt Netz-Dat angemacht und hab die Seite aufgerufen und dann hat er hier pro Sekunde, zeigt an wieviel er runterlädt und es sind einmal 266 Kilo-Byte, 100 Kilo-Byte und 30 Kilo-Byte.
Und das Ganze ohne Adblocker?
Und das Ganze ohne Adblocker. Ich müsste mal natürlich, könnte das gleich jetzt nochmal mit einem Reload machen, dass er wirklich nichts aus dem Cash holen kann. Aber auch das iPhone hat natürlich einen Cash, muss man ja nun mal so sagen.
Aber kein Adblocker.
Ah, doch, gibt's einen.
Okay, jetzt wird's schon erheblich mehr mit einem Reload. Das sind jetzt 100, 450, 800, ne, ein MB. Spiegelhauptzeit ist ein MB, kann man schon so sagen.
Genau. Das war auch so meine Erfahrung.
Aber mit einem Reload, dann holt er wirklich alles.
Ja gut, aber jetzt machst du mal 500 Webseiten in einem Monat. Das ist nicht so viel. Ich meine, das teilst du jetzt mal durch 30, dann hast du irgendwie 10 bis 20 Webseiten pro Tag. 10 bis 20 Webseiten pro Tag. 10 bis 20 Webseiten hau ich dir in einer Stunde durch.
Ja, aber nicht auf dem iPhone.
Aber auf diesem Vertrag mit Multisim. Und warum nicht auch auf dem iPhone? Ich meine, ich surf mit dem iPhone auf denselben Webseiten rum. Ich hab dann noch irgendwie Mail laufen, dann hab ich da noch Apps laufen.
Also ich würde auch sagen, man kommt mit 500 MB relativ weit.
Der Punkt ist, wenn du 500 MB überschreitest, zahlst du für jedes MB 50 Cent. Das heißt, jeder CD-Artikel kostet 50 Cent.
Dafür gibt es ja auch die anderen Verträge.
Ja, ich wollte nur sagen, dass es ein scheiß Tarif ist.
Mehr wollte ich nicht sagen. Ich finde den Tarif eher blöd wegen, um ehrlich zu sein, wegen der extrem hohen Minutenpreise, die er erst denn gekostet hat.
Jungs, es gibt keine scheiß Tarife. Man muss halt gucken, was für einen selbst der richtige Tarif ist. Und wenn so wie ich, wenn ich sage, ich brauch nicht so viel, dann nehme ich halt diesen kleinen Tarif, dann ist es genau der richtige. Wenn du sagst, du willst Multisim benutzen, dann nimmst du natürlich den mit der Flatrate für 49 Euro.
Ist doch klar. Naja, aber es gibt schon scheiß Tarife. Und zwar nämlich die fürs iPhone von der Telekom zum Beispiel.
Naja, ich finde jetzt die Tarife als solche auch nicht so schlimm. Ich finde bloß solche Datenfallen, ich bin ja jetzt selber gerade mal wieder in eine reingetapst. Das hat mich einfach mal richtig. Ich habe mal in Österreich es gewagt, 4, 5, 6 Webseiten runterzuladen. Und das habe ich dann sozusagen nochmal mit so einem Jahrestarif bezahlt. Ja, die haben dann auch andere Größenordnungen. Da kosten mich dann 10 Kilobyte, kosten mich dann halt, hab ich vergessen. Ich hab auf jeden Fall 170 Euro bezahlt, nur weil ich mal eine Adresse nachgeschlagen hab. Und das war schon echt ein bisschen frech.
Ich hab vorher mal bei Otto angerufen, was die eigentlich verlangen dafür in Spanien, das waren 16 Cent pro 10 Kilobyte. Das war, was weiß ich mir, daraufhin auch.
Genau, das ist auch alles modernes Röbertum. Und ich hab ja auch in meinem Rand auf MobileMacs schon beklagt, das ist doch, oder was ist auf meinem Blog, jetzt weiß ich es gerade gar nicht mehr.
Doch, das war auf MobileMacs.
Genau, also es wird einfach mal Zeit für eine europäische Lösung. Und ich finde, Apple sollte sich da auch mal schwer bemühen, weil das kann einfach mal nicht angehen in den USA. Ich mein, okay, ich weiß, ein Provider usw. ist alles viel einfacher. Und es ist halt die USA. Aber die USA ist einfach scheiße groß. Ein Riesennetz. Und da leben weniger Leute als in Europa. In Europa hast du einfach alles viel enger, viel bessere Infrastruktur, alles viel besser, viel enger, näher beieinander. Und die Leute fahren die ganze Zeit hin und her. Ich meine, wir sind auch so halbwegs gut dran. Aber ich meine, Holland, so, Schweizer, gut. Ich meine, die sind einfach unterwegs. Ich meine, wenn die nicht rechtzeitig brennen, dann stehen die auf einmal in Finnland. Dann werden sie aber vorher noch nass. Ja, dann sind sie halt in Dänemark. Du weißt schon, was ich sage.
Nein, da gibt es diese neue Brücke.
Das Problem ist einfach, dir werden die Taschen leer geraubt. Für einen Dienst, der nicht im Ansatz auch nur ein bisschen das Geld wert ist.
Das ist wirklich komplett absurd.
Das ist einfach schlimm und wir prangern das an.
Ich meine, es ist ja bei den Telefon-Roaming-Gebühren nicht, dass die günstig wären oder sowas, aber im Vergleich zu dem, was da noch vor ein paar Jahren üblich war, hat ja einmal mit der großen EU-Gesetzeskeule draufhauen doch einiges gebracht, muss man mal sagen.
Ja, dann gibt es noch eine Neuigkeit, nämlich, das habe ich mit Augenbrauenzucken festgestellt, dass die Rede davon ist, dass das neue iPhone jetzt nicht mehr mit einem SIM-Lok kommt, sondern mit einem NET-Lok, wo ich mich so ein bisschen gefragt habe, ob jetzt ich gerade doof bin oder alle anderen, weil ich eigentlich immer davon ausgegangen ist, dass dieses SIM-Lok natürlich ein Lok auf das Netz ist und nicht auf die einzelne SIM. Das sagt die, ja, aber was heißt denn das? Das heißt, dass wenn ich meine SIM-Karte verliere oder die nicht mehr funktioniert und ich eine neue SIM-Karte kriege, muss ich mein iPhone einschalten, damit es eine neue Firmware kriegt?
Wahrscheinlich einschalten nicht, aber wahrscheinlich wieder über iTunes aktivieren.
Ach so.
Also ich kenne den Fall nicht, ich habe ihn nicht erlebt, aber das ist sozusagen, dass man auch mit einem...
Ja, natürlich, da hast du natürlich recht....
mit einer anderen Karte von AT&T nichts anfangen konnte.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall meinen sie jetzt, man könnte Karten beliebig wechseln, die von Telekom sind. Was ja auch wiederum heißen dürfte, dass man auch andere Tarife nehmen könnte. Ist alles ein bisschen...
Wenn man den 29 Euro-Tarif nimmt, kann man sich wahrscheinlich...
Ich würde sagen, wir warten einfach mal ab.
Ja, aber wenn man jetzt schon einen Telekom-Tarif hat und man will ein iPhone haben, dann muss man doch einen neuen Vertrag abschließen oder seinen eigenen verlängern.
Vielleicht gibt es ja eine Vertragsverlängerung in Zukunft.
Aber man verlängert dann den Tarif, den man eh schon hat.
Also was ich ja sowieso ein hübsches Detail fand, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt drinnen geblieben ist, aber was natürlich sehr dafür sprechen würde, ist, es gab bei dieser iPhone 2.0-Software, hat irgendjemand mal so entdeckt, dass es irgendwo in den Tiefen, in den Einstellungen so einen Button gibt, Telefonbucheinträge von der SIM-Karte importieren.
Ja, gibt's, hab ich schon gesehen.
Und dieser Button macht ja nur Sinn, wenn man eine alte SIM-Karte recyceln kann, sozusagen. Also wenn man aus seinem alten Telefon die SIM-Karte rausnehmen kann und in sein neues iPhone reinschieben kann irgendwie.
Das ist vielleicht auch für AT&T-Kunden, die schon einen Vertrag haben.
Genau, für Leute, die...
Und auch letztes Jahr schon hatten aber. Nicht vom vorherigen iPhone, sondern so vorher von einem anderen Phone schon.
Ja, genau, davon spreche ich doch. Und das spricht ja sehr dafür, dass es in Zukunft auch irgendwann mal sowas geben wird, dass man mit einem bestehenden Vertrag ankommt und sagt, hallo, ich hätte gerne jetzt als neues Telefon ein iPhone. Und dafür nicht extra großartig den mega Niegelnagel neuen Vertrag abschließen muss. Sondern zumindest eine SIM-Karte weiterverwenden kann.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Mir ist ja noch nicht so ganz klar, wie das läuft für Bestandskunden. Wir wissen das auch noch nicht so ganz genau.
Ich warte mal, wie war das? Also das ist natürlich auch von Land zu Land unterschiedlich. Ich glaube, bei T-Mobile kannst du ein neues iPhone haben, wenn du dich für weitere zwei Jahre bindest. Oder eine Ablösegebühr zahlst, eine Vertragsablösegebühr.
Das kommt noch dazu. Und dann je nachdem, wie viele Monate das her ist. Und es lohnt sich. Du kannst das nur machen, wenn du mindestens sechs Monate schon einen Vertrag hast oder so ein Kram. Also es ist wieder so eine Lösung, wo ich mich auch echt frage, warum macht ihr das alles so kompliziert? Warum kann ich nicht einfach sagen, das funktioniert für die Business-mäßig? Naja, wie auch immer. Was mich sehr verwundert hat, ist, dass das iPhone von Apple beworben wird mit Twice as Fast.
Das sollte eigentlich ein bisschen mehr als Twice sein, oder?
Aber hallo, ich meine, das Ding kann HSDPA, das heißt, das ist hier, dürfte das nicht Twice as Fast sein, sondern...
Was sie mit Twice as Fast meinen ist, sie haben doch den Vergleich gemacht, wie schnell der Browser irgendwie eine Seite aufbaut.
Also ich glaube ja, das hat eine Menge damit zu tun, dass Steve Jobs uns letztes Jahr noch erzählt hat, dass Edge mehr als schnell genug ist.
Das ist lahm in den USA. Das LTE 3G ist nicht so schnell wie hier.
Aber ich glaube, es hat sehr viel damit zu tun, dass man natürlich Bestandskunden nicht sagen möchte, was wir euch letztes Jahr erzählt haben, dass das schnell wäre. Es war komplett gelogen. HSDPA ist eigentlich das schnelle Ding. Also letztes Jahr, wie gesagt.
Ich kann mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, dass das iPhone in Europa besser performt als ein USB-A.
Das ist ein Web-Ladetest. Die Leute interessiert nicht, was von HSDPA gehört. Die wollen wissen, wie schnell der Browser ist. Er hat es vorgeführt und da war der Browser doppelt so schnell.
Das hängt aber auch immer von der Seite ab, die man aufruft.
Ja klar, die haben da diese, was haben sie auch? National Geographic haben sie doch genommen, die Seite als Test, oder? Wie schnell die unter Edge kommt, wie schnell die unter UMTS kommt und wie schnell die unter WLAN kommt. Mit UMTS war es fast so schnell, wie mit WLAN.
Wobei sie nicht gesagt haben, was für eine Internetverbindung dahinter hinter dem WLAN ist.
Ist doch klar, die sagen nie irgendwas, aber...
Ich fand das alles ganz schön fischig.
Das sind alle Benchmarks, die halt nur einer macht, wo er nicht weiß, wie der gemacht wird.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall nicht schlauer geworden dadurch.
Doch, doppelt so schnell.
Na okay, dann ist es halt doppelt so schnell.
Also doppelt so schnell wird jetzt eine Aussage, auf die ich mich auch nicht unbedingt festlegen würde.
Ja, was wir letztes Mal auch schon besprochen haben... Achso, nee warte mal, ich wollte noch was anderes kommen. Es gibt ja dann wieder diese Gerüchteküche, was das Ding irgendwie kostet. Und iSupply, die jetzt nicht unbedingt als bringer, zuverlässiger, belastbarer Informationen sind, meinen, so ein iPhone kostet im Zusammenbauen 173 Dollar.
Entschuldigung, das hab ich auch gelesen. Das letzte iPhone, weil sie wohl, obwohl die zusätzlichen Chips drin sind, für die anderen Bauteile jetzt eine Menge Geld einsparen, weil die billiger geworden sind.
Und an der anderen Stelle habe ich jetzt aber leider keine Quelle. Heißt es, dass diese Subsidi-Provider-Zahlen an Apple 325 Dollar beträgt.
Oder sogar 425, falls der Vertrag im Apple-Laden abgeschlossen wird.
Okay, dann mal die Provision.
Ach echt? 100 Dollar kriegen sie ja nochmal.
Aber das wäre wahrscheinlich...
Ich habe ja gesagt, dass irgendwo müssen die ihr Geld herkriegen.
Ja klar, aber was heißt denn das? Das heißt, ich gehe in Apple Store, in USA, kaufe mir da dieses 3G und mache einen 2-Jahres-Vertrag mit AT&T. Daraufhin zahlt AT&T an Apple...
425 Dollar. Aber... Munkelt man.
Und die 199 Kaufpreis, an wen gehen die?
Na auch an Apple. Die muss ja AT&T auch abführen, muss ja die iPhones irgendwie eingekauft haben.
So, das heißt, 425 plus 199, 624 Dollar, gehen bei Apple auf den Tisch, für ein verkauftes iPhone, 24 Dollar mehr.
Möglicherweise, möglicherweise. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass das sozusagen, dass die 199, dass die sich AT&T einsteckt und 325 an Apple komplett überweist, pro iPhone sozusagen.
Auf jeden Fall glaube ich, dass die Bude Geld macht mit diesen Teilen.
Naja, ich meine, das sind ja mehr als...
Deswegen machen die das ja mit der Vertragsbindung und so weiter und so fort.
Klar machen die damit Geld, aber ich meine, das sind gerade bei so einem relativ neuen Produkt wie so einem iPhone, da sind ja immer noch extrem hohe Research and Development Kosten dabei.
Klar, aber ich meine, es gibt auf jeden Fall keinen Zweifel, dass Apple mit dem iPhone ordentlich Geld verdienen und zwar halt nicht...
Nicht verdienen, ja.
Das kostet halt nicht 190. Ich versuche mir ja nur herzutasten, was ist der eigentliche Preis? Angenommen, es gäbe dieses Modell nicht. Angenommen, das wäre so was wie ein iPod. Vor allem, wie teuer wird jetzt der nächste iPod Touch? Das ist auch so ein bisschen das, was ich mich frage. Weil jetzt alles billiger geworden ist. Und wenn man ein iPhone schon für 173 Dollar bauen kann... Und ein iPod Touch hat diese ganze Geschichte ja nicht. 30% ist so die Marge bei Apple. Ich mache eine Milchmädchenrechnung auf.
Eine totale. Und zwar eben auch dadurch, dass das ja keine Gewinnmarge ist, sondern dass ja eben auch die 173 Dollar, die das Zusammenbauen eines Telefons kostet, kommt nochmal das Geld, was du abschlägst, über den Laufe der Entwicklungszeit. Und nehmen wir mal an, die haben eine Milliarde oder sowas in das scheiß iPhone gesteckt, bevor sie es überhaupt erstmal verkaufen konnten.
Aber es wird nicht in die offizielle Marge mit eingerechnet. Die Marge ist Production-Kost minus Verkaufspreis. Und das, was da in Differenz übrig bleibt, ist die Marge. Und die liegt bei Apple halt derzeit so zwischen 26 und 30%.
Das hängt immer vom Gerät ab, oder?
Über alle Produkte. Im Einzelnen sagen sie das nicht.
Ich dachte beim iPod wären es um die 50%, habe ich mal gehört.
Wie ich schon sagte, über alle Produkte. Das ist das, was Sie quarterly in Ihren Finanzreports müssen Sie das angeben. Wir sagen, was Sie so für ein Average Marge haben an Ihren Dingern. Und so nach dem, was ich bisher immer an Beispielrechnungen gesehen habe, kann man davon ausgehen, dass 25, 30, 35%. Ob nun der eine oder andere iPod jetzt besonders billig hergestellt werden kann, aber ich denke nicht, dass sie so wirklich auf 50%...
Also ich hab irgendwann mal zwischendurch...
So viel hat eigentlich keiner. Wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, dass der iPod Touch könnte günstiger werden auf jeden Fall. Darauf will ich eigentlich hinaus. Man kann so einen 8GB, 16GB teilen.
Was hat der letzte gekostet?
Gute Frage. Was hat er gekostet, die Frage ist.
Ansonsten müssen wir mal Thema wechseln, sonst haben wir gleich eine komplette Sendung mit iPhone. Langsam ist du.
Und ich weiß, euch interessiert das alle nicht die Bohne, aber nachher ist Fußball.
Eine Sache hab ich noch.
Ach, wir gewinnen eh.
Wieso interessiert mich das nicht die Bohne? Ich hoffe nur, dass du hier schnell genug alle Fragen beantwortest, damit wir dann auch rechtzeitig in den Fernseher kommen.
Mit dem iPhone sind wir durch, oder?
Eine Sache hab ich noch. Wir hatten auch letztes Mal darüber geredet, dass TomTom seine Software anbieten will. Und dann gab es auch dieses Gerücht, dass Apples Lizenzbedingungen sowas nicht erlauben.
Ja, aber das ist eine normale versicherungstechnische Absicherung, also was sie immer so schreiben. Ich glaube, das hat TomTom auch schon gesagt.
Das heißt, sie sind entspannt und TomTom wird trotzdem kommen?
Wurde ja auch wieder ein bisschen ruhig danach, aber ich meine, klar wollen sie aufs iPhone rauf.
Natürlich wollen sie aufs iPhone rauf, aber Apple wird nicht jeden aufs iPhone drauflassen. Ich hab ja...
Wen werden sie drauflassen? Ich meine, das Programm kommt genauso in AppStore wie alle anderen. Apple kriegt seine 30 Prozent. Warum sollen sie denn nicht drauflassen?
Weil es bestimmte Software gibt, die für sie nicht gut ist.
Welche zum Beispiel?
Na, haben sie ja auch schon gesagt, Porno wollen sie halt nicht draufhaben.
Ja, das ist ja verständlich.
Und sie werden sicherlich auch...
Wieso ist das verständlich eigentlich?
Aus deren Sicht.
Naja, weil Apple, Konsumer, Jugendliche, lalala, das ist eher so eine Marketing-Sache, wie sie in der Öffentlichkeit darstellen. Das hat was mit ihrem Brand zu tun. Und ich hab ja letzte Woche einen Chaos Radio Express Podcast gemacht zu Computerspielen. Einen sehr langen Podcast, Nummer 89, wo die ganze Geschichte Computerspiele von 80er Jahren Schwerpunkt Deutschland so erklärt wird und auch viele andere Dynamiken in dieser Branche.
Der hat sogar schon mehrfach empfohlen worden. Ich hab ihn zwar natürlich.
Wie schön. Und wir hatten da auch eine Sektion zum iPhone, weil der Toit, der da war, hatte halt auch selber ein iPhone. Da musste ich ihn natürlich mal gleich fragen. Und er war extrem positiv, was den Spielemarkt auf dem iPhone betrifft. Und seine Theorie war halt auch immer so, es gibt immer komischerweise in der Spiele-Hardware-Szene bei den Konsolen gibt es komischerweise immer so drei. Es gibt immer drei Player gerade auf dem Markt. So wie derzeit halt die Nintendo Wii, die Xbox 360 und die Playstation 3 sich da in diesem Konsolenmarkt streiten, gab es halt ganz früher auch Atari VCS und irgendwie ColecoVision und so weiter. Und im Handheld-Bereich fehlt halt noch einer. Da gibt es halt die Nintendo DS und die Sony PlayStation Portable. Und er sieht halt, dass iPhone an der Stelle kommt. Und wenn man eben die Voraussetzungen, die ein Spielerentwickler erfüllen muss, um für eine Plattform Software zu veröffentlichen, sich anschaut, die bei Nintendo herrschen und die bei Sony herrschen. Im Vergleich zu dem, wie es jetzt bei Apple aussieht, haben sie da einen riesen Vorteil. Weil wenn du überhaupt erst mal Software für die DS machen willst, dann musst du auf jeden Fall schon mal 50.000 Dollar erst mal irgendwo auf den Tisch legen.
Was natürlich beim iPhone da auch nochmal richtig schön reinknallt ist, du hast ja quasi keine Distributionskosten. Ich meine, wenn du bei einer PSP und bei einer Nintendo DS musst du erst mal Cartridges produzieren, musst du in jeden Laden packen, musst eine Verpackung drum rum packen, brauchst ein weltweites Vertriebsnetzwerk fürs iPhone.
Du musst die alle mal vorproduzieren lassen, das wusste ich ja auch nicht. Du hast natürlich schon auch Vertriebskosten, weil Apple streicht ja 30% ein.
Klar, aber im Zweifelsfall habe ich keinen furchtbar hohen Verlust gemacht, wenn ich nur 10 Kopien verkaufe, außer natürlich meine Entwicklungskosten.
Und vor allem, bevor du anfangen kannst, musst du halt bei den anderen schon riesige Summen ausgeben für deine Developer-Lizenzen. Und dann hast du halt keine Ahnung, welche Qualitätsgüte dann die Dinge haben, aber wir wissen alle, mit Xcode hat Apple ein durchaus passables Entwicklungssystem. Man braucht einen Macintosh und man muss noch 100 Dollar zahlen, und man kann loslegen. Wenn man denn aufgenommen wird, weil Apple hat ja bisher immer noch nicht alle, die das SDK haben wollen, auch wirklich das Programm aufgenommen. Da habe ich trotzdem, also nur um das zu Ende zu bringen. Spiele-Software auf dem iPhone.
Warte, aber das SDK kriegt man auch so ohne 99 Dollar, weil ich hab das ja auch.
Ja, aber du kannst das nicht auf deinem iPhone installieren. Du kannst es nur in dem Simulator machen.
Nur über Zeit, du kriegst die neueste Firmware für das iPhone. Ich muss halt im Simulator-Code.
Genau, und im Simulator ist es nicht das selbe. Du hast es nicht in der Hand, du kannst die Sensoren nicht so benutzen. Oder macht dieser Simulator auch den Beschleunigungs-Sensor?
Ne, aber drehen kannst du den Simulator, meine ich.
Du kannst das Fenster drehen.
Aber cool wäre, wenn sie eigentlich so dem Sensor, der Mac ist, einfach durchreichen.
Ich glaube, das würde zu viel kaputter Hardware werden.
Okay, wen das interessiert, diesen Teil zum iPhone, ich will das jetzt nicht komplett wiederholen, das würde mir jetzt auch nicht gelingen, der kann mal bei ChaosRadio Express 89 reinhorchen.
Aber über einen Teil...
Hast du jetzt Werbung gemacht?
Ich hab Werbung gemacht.
Ich hab kein Bock mehr auf iPhone. Was mir am meisten gefällt an dieser iPhone 2.0-Software, ist ein Teil, der überhaupt noch nicht fertig ist. Auf der einen Seite hab ich vor dem ein bisschen Angst, auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch eine schöne Sache, dieser Notification-Dienst. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass auf dem iPhone dürfen ja Programme nicht im Hintergrund laufen, wie alle jetzt mitbekommen haben, Eigenentwickelte.
Du hast aber, man merkt, dass du den Podcasts in den letzten nicht gehört hast.
Ach, da habt ihr darüber geredet.
Natürlich haben wir darüber geredet.
Na gut.
Wir haben über alles eigentlich schon geredet. Wir haben eigentlich die Themen der nächsten 10 Podcasts schon vorweg genommen.
Mist.
Und du weißt nicht, welche es sind, aber sag doch mal trotzdem, was dein Punkt ist.
Der Punkt ist, dass sowas eigentlich... Ich frag mich seit Jahren, wieso sowas kein Telefonanbieter anbietet. Weil es ist ja auf kleinen Telefonen wie die nur Java können, ist das ja noch mal viel, viel schlimmer. Oder nicht schlimmer, sondern genauso schlimm. Da hab ich ja auch diese Problematik. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, mich über irgendwas zu benachrichtigen oder wenn ich ein Programm im Hintergrund packe, verbraucht das unglaublich viel Rechenzeit. Nur, damit es darauf wartet, dass da irgendwie von draußen ein Ping kommt. Und jetzt hat Apple diese Möglichkeit geschaffen. Sei es über ihren eigenen Server, worüber ich nicht ganz so glücklich bin. Aber, dass sie den zentralen Dienst hochziehen, der benachrichtigt werden kann.
Was natürlich auch ein Problem ist.
Man informiert auch mein Telefon.
Man muss es aber schon sehr spezifisch machen. Also ich meine, ein Jobber-Server wirst du da nicht ran gebubbt bekommen. Ich denke mal, das ist so für...
Also ich denke mal, als Zusatzlösung wäre es ganz schick. Aber als einziges für Background-Applications ist es nicht so schick. Zusätzlich wär es toll.
Es ist bisher noch nicht die perfekte Lösung, aber es ist ein Ansatz in die richtige Richtung. Ich glaube, dass es in Zukunft die Möglichkeit geben wird, und das war ja immer die Frage, die sich bei der Vorstellung des SDKs alle gefragt haben, da ist jetzt AOL vorgestellt worden, dass die einen Instant-Messenger entwickeln fürs neue iPhone. Wie machen die das denn überhaupt, wenn es gar nicht im Hintergrund möglich ist? Jetzt ist klar, wie sie es machen.
Ich glaube, da war es denen auch noch nicht klar. Und diese Erweitung kommt ja auch erst im September. Es riecht ganz stark danach, als wenn Apple da ganz spät gemerkt hat, dass es so nicht geht ohne Background-Applications. Und dass du deswegen nachlegen musst und deswegen auch noch nicht fertig bist.
Aber ich finde die Lösung eigentlich relativ elegant. Also es ist kein Ersatz für Programme, die im Hintergrund laufen. Aber es ist, sagen wir so...
Sie haben ja überhaupt nicht gesagt, wie es funktioniert. Also ich meine, das, was Sie da angekündigt haben, Frau Wischewaschi, wir wissen natürlich nicht, was Sie jetzt auf der WWDC erzählt haben. Das ist ja alles NDA, aber was bisher bekannt ist, muss ich sagen, ich lasse mir da noch keine... Aber wir haben das wie gesagt schon beim nächsten Mal jetzt ausführlich diskutiert. Ich würde ganz gern da ein bisschen voranschreiten. Ich habe hier noch ein anderes Thema, von dem du gerade meintest, wir hätten das schon, also mit dem LLVM im GCC.
Das hat man ja erwähnt. Die aktuelle Version von Xcode ist 3.0, was man normal runterladen kann. Und wenn man aber sich... Also man kann ja hier so online sich als Developer registrieren, kostet ja auch nichts. Und selbst dann kann man sich das iPhone SDK runterladen. Und da ist eine 3.1 Beta dabei. Eigentlich stehe ich auch unter NDA, oder? Verdammt. Aber das kann man ja sehen. Das steht ja auf der Webseite, dass man, wenn man sich da einträgt, auch ein iPhone SDK steht. Das ist ja alles okay. Und da ist ja jedenfalls eine Version 3.1 Beta. Inzwischen die... Ich weiß gar nicht, die siebte auch, oder so? Ja, das glaube ich auch die siebte. Das ist der Synchron zur iPhone 2.0 Beta-Geschichte. Und dort ist also der normale Compiler bei Xcode war immer der GCC 4.0.1. Und bei diesem 3.1 Xcode ist auch ein 4.2.0 bei, also ein bisschen eine neuere Version. Und zusätzlich aber auch noch ein sogenannter LLVM GCC, auch in Version 4.2.0. Und der kompiliert halt ein bisschen anders, um das jetzt mal ganz salopp auszudrücken. Ich glaube, ich hatte das schon mal ganz kurz erwähnt. Der LLVM nutzt glaube ich den GCC Präprozessor, um den C oder C++ Code erst mal durchzupasen und erstellt dann aber so eine Art...
Er benutzt das vollständige Frontend. Also das GCC LLVM ist sozusagen das Backend, die Code-Generierung wird ausgetauscht und es wird nicht mehr das, was beim GCC dabei ist, genommen, sondern es wird halt LLVM als Backend benutzt. Aber das Frontend ist dasselbe. Das heißt, der GCC liest nach wie vor den Source Code ein und baut sich sein TRI, AST heißt das glaube ich beim GCC, also sozusagen der abstrakte Syntax-TRI, was er sozusagen meint, was das ist, also die interne Repräsentierung. Und die Arbeit, die halt das LLVM-Team geleistet hat an der Stelle, ist ein Konverter. Ein Konverter von der internen Repräsentierung des GCC in die interne Repräsentierung von Code des LLVM.
So eine Art Byte-Code könnte man sagen. Und das auch nicht mehr auf einzelne Files, sondern alles zusammen, also noch vorm linken.
Moment, darf ich mal ganz kurz dazwischen gehen? Ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer, worüber ihr redet. LLVM, wofür steht das überhaupt? Also VM klingt ja nach virtuellem nicht.
Also wovon wir überhaupt reden, dann machen wir mal die Klammer ganz auf. Also wir reden über Xcode. Das ist die Entwicklungsumgebung vom Mac und auch die Entwicklungsumgebung für das iPhone. Darin programmiert man Anwendungen. So, man schreibt die in Objective-C und das Tool, was halt dein Objective-C-Programm in laufendem Code übersetzt, das ist der GNU-C-Compiler oder die GNU-Compiler Collection, wie auch immer man das nennen möchte. GPL-Software, weit verbreitet, die Apple schon seit Anfang an benutzt. Und der GCC ist ein altes Pferd. Der wird zwar auch immer wieder so ein bisschen besser, aber es gibt mittlerweile diverse Demonstrationen, wo man klar sehen kann, man könnte so viel erreichen, wenn. Und das sichtbarste Projekt derzeit im Internet zu dem Thema Performance und Flexibilität ist LLVM, Low Level Virtual Machine. Was ein komischer Name ist, der einen auch ein bisschen erstmal in die falsche Richtung führt. Im Prinzip musst du dir vorstellen, LLVM ist so eine große Bibliothek an einzelnen Modulen, die man benötigt für Compiler-Umgebung aller Art. Vor allem konzentriert sich LLVM um eine effiziente Code-Generierung und Ausführung und basiert eben auf einer Low Level Virtual Machine. Das ist sozusagen das Herz der ganzen Geschichte. Im Gegensatz zu den Code-Generatoren, wie man sie heutzutage in GCC und so weiter hat, brilliert dieses LLVM, mit dem es sehr viel mehr über den Code weiß, sehr viel mehr über Typen weiß und so ne Sachen. Und einfach schnell ist. Darüber hinaus ist es auch sprachenunabhängig. Alle möglichen Sprachen könnten im Prinzip nach LLVM kompilen. Und mit jeder Portierung von LLVM auf eine neue Prozessor-Architektur hätte man dann eben auch diese Sprache dann wieder dabei und so weiter.
Zum Beispiel hat Apple irgendwie den Arm-Port von LLVM gesponsert, wo ich schon damals gesagt hab, dass es ja eigentlich nur fürs iPhone sein kann. Und genau so war es auch.
Und dieses... Hat es gerade geklingelt?
Ja, es hat geklingelt. Ich muss wohl noch mal kurz hingehen.
Und solange frag ich dich mal kurz.
Ja, frag mal, genau.
Gut, und dieses LLVM, das ist dann schneller, besser, höher, weiter oder...
Na, das LLVM nimmt den Code und erzeugt so eine Art Byte-Code, so wie man es ja von Java kennt, auch wenn man es ja nur hört und eigentlich nie richtig sieht. Man hat ja seine C-Files in vielen einzelnen Files. Aus diesen Punkt C-Files entstehen dann lauter Punkt O-Files. Die werden dann vom Linker zusammen gelinkt und danach kann nicht mehr optimiert werden. Das heißt, wenn man Optimierungen zwischen zwei Object-Files, also den Punkt O-Files, vornehmen könnte, geht das nicht, weil der GCC macht das nicht mehr. Bei LLVM wird alles zusammen in einen Byte-Code getan und dann kann er übers gesamte Spektrum optimieren. Er sieht viel mehr.
Also er kennt nicht nur die einzelnen kleinen Bausteile, sondern er kennt auch das große Ganze.
Genau, er kann nicht nur Inhalte der einzelnen Files optimieren, sondern auch im Großen und Ganzen. Und auch durch diesen Byte-Code kann er auch noch viel mehr entdecken, was der GCC designmäßig einfach nicht konnte.
Und vor allem die Speed-Gains sind signifikant. Also dieser GCC LLVM kann 33% schnelleren Code erzeugen.
Wow.
Im Durchschnitt sagen die Leute. Ich werde es demnächst mal testen, aber so sagen sie es.
Aber was ich jetzt mal ganz spannend finde, ist, was wird dann an mich als End-User ausgeliefert? Kriege ich nach wie vor Maschinencode? Kriege ich vielleicht einen Minimal-Runtime mit diesem LLVM drin? Oder vielleicht auch in die Bibliothek, ins Betriebssystem einbinden?
Da bist du schon genau auf der richtigen Spur, weil es wird auf der LLVM-Homepage, oder wenn Sie in den Foren berichten, Sie sagen, dass Sie eigentlich auch den Byte-Code ausliefern könnten und dann zur Laufzeit anfangen, den Code zu optimieren.
Und genau in dem Bereich ist Apple auch relativ weit vorne, was die Grafikkarte angeht. Quartz-Extreme-Code glaube ich teilweise, dass der erst zur Laufzeit auf die Grafikkarte angepasst wird.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Nein, die Geschichte ist ein bisschen anders. Bei OpenGL gibt es viele, viele Features. Und wenn das Feature auf der Grafikkarte funktioniert, dann macht die Grafikkarte das halt. Also hier gibt es ja verschiedene, weißt du das eigentlich bei OpenGL, Versionen oder diese Features, hier nennt man die, weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, aber es gibt halt verschiedene Sachen.
Bestimmte Features gehen halt dann nicht auf der Grafikkarte und das muss halt dann weiter in die CPU machen. Also du hast sozusagen die Grafikkarte nicht kann, wenn du nicht gerade die super Neues hast, muss halt die CPU machen.
Genau, okay.
Und da muss halt ein Code...
Na, muss überhaupt erst mal existieren und wenn du nicht hast, hast du halt das Feature nicht und du musst das Feature halt machen. Apple hat es mit LLVM realisiert. Das heißt, sie haben LLVM genommen und haben ihren ganzen OpenGL-Treiber komplett neu geschrieben. Und das heißt, dass ein Feature auf einem Rechner, wo die Grafikkarte das eben nicht kann, das aber trotzdem angeboten werden soll, schneller läuft, als das vorher war, weil es jetzt auch multithreaded ist.
Weil da wird auch so eine Art Sprache interpretiert.
Ja genau, da ist ja so ein Interpreter dabei, dass man nämlich den Code nicht doppelt schreiben muss, einmal für die Grafikkarte sozusagen und einmal für den Prozessor, sondern dass der entsprechende Grafikkartentreiber sich das dynamisch zusammensuchen kann. Ah, das kann ich, also mach ich das selber. Oder eben das an die CPU, ohne dass man das doppelt entwickeln muss. Wenn ich das jetzt nicht komplett missverstanden habe.
Das war schon ungefähr so, dass es LL vor allem schneller interpretieren von diesen Art Skript Sprache war. Das kann man sicher auch nicht sagen, aber das ist ein bisschen low-level jetzt.
Passt das nicht, ist das nicht... Ich finde das gerade sehr spannend, weil das ist doch so ein wunderschöner Puzzle-Stein, mit dem in die Richtung, um jetzt mal die Glaskugel vielleicht mal ein bisschen zusammenzusetzen, wohin es in Zukunft mit Apple gehen könnte. Wenn man jetzt Snow Leopard, ein Thema, das man auch gar nicht angeschlossen hat, in dieser Sendung habt ihr wahrscheinlich eine Let's-Gesendung.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass in der Zukunft LL vor allem Byte-Code ausgeliefert wird.
Genau, und da ich ja gehört habe, dass Snow Leopard so unglaublich auf Tausende von Prozessoren, also nicht auf Tausende, aber auf Multikern-Prozessoren optimiert sein soll, soll werden soll, würde das natürlich nochmal super mit reinpassen, dass man möglicherweise sagt, okay wir entwickeln Code, der dadurch durch die zur Laufzeit-bynamische Zusammensetzbarkeit auch sehr gut auf mehreren Kern gleichzeitig...
Sie werden einfach ihr OS mit dem LLVM übersetzen und es wird einfach schon dadurch schneller werden. Also LLVM ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz fette Geschichte. Und Apple war einfach extrem klug, sich diesen Chris Lettner direkt einzukaufen. Das spielt eine riesen Rolle, vor allem es geht ja noch weiter. Jetzt haben wir erst mal GCC LLVM, das ist der erste Schritt. Das andere Projekt...
Wo GCC immer noch frontend ist, was aber demnächst dann auch abgelöst wird.
Genau, es gibt noch ein anderes interessantes Projekt. Und das ist jetzt auch das erste Mal released worden. In der Version, genau, C-Lang, in der Version 2.3, die, oh, Wunder, oh, Wunder, einen Tag vor der WWDC released wurde. Ja, also das aktuelle LLVM-Release 2.3 ist halt einen Tag vor der WWDC rausgekommen. Das spielt irgendwie alles wunderbar zusammen.
Das war letztes Jahr auch schon so.
Sie haben da ganz viele interessante Sachen drin, unter anderem eben C-Lang. C-Lang ist im Prinzip das Replacement für den GCC.
Wie schreibt man das denn? C-Lang?
C-L-A-N-G. Und C-Lang ist halt noch nicht fertig, aber da machen sie dann eben das, was noch fehlt, also das Frontend. Das heißt, sie haben sich einen kompletten neuen Pre-Prozessor gebaut und ich hab mal einen Vortrag gesehen von dem Lepner, wo er Performance-Vergleiche von C-Lang und GCC gezeigt hat. Ich weiß jetzt die Zahlen nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber es war so im Vielfachen. Also sowas wie zehnmal so schnell. Kann der halt einfach sich durch den Sourcecode wühlen. Und vor allem wird natürlich dieses Frontend dann auch sehr viel mehr über das Backend wissen. Sprich, das ist dann eben der Compiler, der das LLVM auch komplett bedient.
So ein bisschen ähnlich wie ZFS, oder? Es sind so ein paar Obstruction-Layer irgendwie weggefallen und hat mehr Übersicht, weil ZFS kann man ja auch so ein bisschen...
Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt, weil das ganze Fallsystem und Compiler-Technologie zu vergleichen ist schwierig. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Wir wollen es jetzt nicht unnötig komplizieren. Tatsache ist, C-Lang ist auf dem Weg. Und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn C-Lang in, naja, nicht allzu ferner Zukunft auch die Chance hätte, der Default-Compiler zu werden bei Xcode. Ich weiß nicht, was die interne Einschätzung ist, wie weit sie davon entfernt sind. Aber es gibt eine Sache, zwei Sachen, die extrem dafür sprechen. Erstens, das Development. Also wenn du dem Developern ein System liefern kannst, was einfach zehnmal so schnell übersetzt wie vorher, die küssen dir die Füße. Weil einfach die Turnaround-Zeit, das kostet richtig Zeit beim Programmieren. Das ist einfach richtig. Deswegen kaufen sie sich auch immer die schnellsten Maschinen mit noch mal mehr Cores, damit einfach ihr dickes, fettes Programm schnell durchkompiliert werden kann, wenn sich mal was geändert hat. Wenn das Thema so schnell geht, hurra! Der zweite Grund, den ich sehe, warum Apple ganz massiv hinterher ist, ist der LLVM ist unter BSD-Lizenz, GCC ist GPL. Und das Problem ist, dass du X-Code mit dem GCC nicht verheiraten kannst. Du kannst das da nicht reinlinken, weil die GPL das verbietet. Das LLVM Zeug und C-Lang ist BSD-Lizenz, das können die miteinander vermunkeln, wie sie wollen und das ist natürlich etwas, was man möchte. Man möchte eine interaktive IDE haben, die möglichst, weißt du, du willst einfach deinen Code aufklappen darunter und direkt die Assembler-Repräsentierung sehen. Du möchtest einfach, dass das alles eins ist und das lässt sich einfach mit GPL-Code nicht machen, wenn du eben nicht sowieso selber auch GPL-Code machst und das macht Apple nun mal nicht. Von daher denke ich mal, hat das eine riesige Zukunft.
Ich denke auch, dass das sehr interessant wird.
Da ist wirklich viel Performance noch zu holen und da sind wir erst am Anfang. Dieses LLVM 2.3 hat übrigens auch noch so ganz nebenbei noch ein anderes Modul, nämlich das VM-Kit. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt in LLVM auch die Unterstützung für andere VMs, unter anderem die Java Virtual Machine. Sowas können sie damit halt auch machen. Und eine CLI-Implementierung. Das ist die Virtual Machine von.NET. Also das ist alles extrem kapabel und da steckt eigentlich die ganze Zukunft drin. Also ich sehe das zumindest so, dass LLVM einfach der Pfad ist und das ist das heißeste Projekt im Developer-Bereich, das Apple verfolgt. Und ich denke, dass viel von dem, was bei Snow Leopard angekündigt wurde, in Bezug auf Multiprocessing und Speed im Allgemeinen mit LLVM zu tun hat. So, jetzt hatten wir uns zu Snow Leopard, Schnee Leo haben wir es genannt. Ausführlich geäußert. Letztes Mal. Was da alles so geplant ist. Du hast jetzt noch ein bisschen geguckt, wa, Dennis?
Bei Snow Leopard. Schnee Leo heißt es. Schnee Leo, ja. Was gerade so aktuell seit zwei, drei Tagen durch die Foren geistert ist, dass ja, wie auch Apple schon sagte, dass es ja so viel dünneren Footprint hätte, also viel kleiner von der Installation ist. Und da fangen sie jetzt an zu vergleichen, dass irgendwie der Application-Order war vorher...
Mail-up von 280 auf 91 MB.
Genau. Und dann haben sie alle spekuliert, dass ja in Snow Leopard irgendwie zum Beispiel der PowerPC-Code nicht mehr mit drin wäre.
Aber das ist ja ganz wenig, ne?
Das ist ja totaler Blödsinn auch, weil er ist noch drin. Also der Kern ist sogar noch PowerPC. Also es wird mich nicht wundern, wenn demnächst auch einer, also Snow Leopard oder den Schneeleo auf PowerPC bootet. Hab ich selber leider noch nicht probiert, war noch zu faul bisher. Aber der ist jedenfalls noch da. Das andere ist, dass immerhin die Sprachen wegfallen würden. Das ist auch nicht der Fall. Oder dass halt durch, weiß nicht, vielleicht auch vor allem die Binaries kleiner sind. Das ist halt auch alles nicht der Fall. Die Binaries sind noch so groß wie vorher.
Sind doch die Binaries spielen noch eine relativ geringe Rolle beim Umfang von Applikationen?
Das kommt noch dazu.
Was ist denn kleiner?
Was ist kleiner?
Ich muss ja langsam aufholen. Was hier so an falschen Gerüchten sind, muss man erstmal wieder legen. Ich hab gestern mal wieder McHackers Org einen Artikel geschrieben, der wurde auch gleich verlinkt von irgendwie einer anderen Seite. Die haben dann gleich auf mich gezeigt, dass einer wohl Ahnung haben müsste. McHackers Org? Ja, ein bisschen Schleicherbo gerade gemacht. Jedenfalls der Grund ist, dass in jedem File, was auch ein GUI-Benutzer mit dem Interface-Bilder gemacht wurde, sind diese sogenannten NIP-Files. Und natürlich auch, wenn nur 20 Sprachen unterstützt, sind die NIP-Files auch dementsprechend oft vorhanden, weil du musst das GUI für jede Sprache machen, weil der Text ist im GUI ja dann anders. Es ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen blöd gelöst, finde ich jedenfalls als Developer, aber ist halt so. Und dort sind immer zwei Files innerhalb von so einem NIP-File. Einmal keyed-objects und einmal designable.nip. Und dieses designable NIP fällt jetzt weg. Und das war immer riesengroß. Und so ist zum Beispiel von MailApp der Sprachenordner, also der deutsche Sprachenordner war vorher 15 Megabyte groß und der ist jetzt auf 4 Megabyte geschrumpft. Und das ist für alle 15 Sprachen so. Und das ist das, was sie auf Snowlapp hat einsparen. Man kann jetzt aber auch nicht mehr mit dem Interface-Bilder, so wie früher, das GUI von MailApp öffnen und da irgendwie drin rumeditieren, weil man kriegt sozusagen nur noch die kompilierte NIP-Version und nicht mehr die Source fehlt sozusagen.
Also ich mach hier gerade mal die...
Und was ich noch entdeckt hab, steht in dem Artikel aber nicht, weil unter 10.4 waren dann noch drei Files drin und die hießen noch ganz anders, die hießen nämlich noch Key.NIP oder Keylist oder irgendwie so. Und dann unter 10.5 haben sie es umgestellt, dann hieß es jetzt Designable und Keyed Objects. Dann waren es nur noch zwei NIP-Files und jetzt unter 10.6 ist es nur noch ein File. Und das heißt halt nur noch Keyed Objects.
Aber warte mal ganz kurz. Also ich hab jetzt hier gerade mal meinen German-L-Project-Orner vom...
Na dann geh mal jetzt drauf, du kannst jetzt hier... Öffne mal so ein Ding. Also nicht mit Doppelklick, sondern jetzt hier...
Ich lass mir noch mal den Paketenhalt anzeigen. Zum Beispiel in dem Fall jetzt von Mail-Sorter, weil er sehr größer ist.
Du hast da noch zwei Dinger drin.
Ah, und da ist die Designable.nipp und die KeyObjects.nipp und die... Und die Designable ist 508 Kilo-Byte groß, die andere ist 72 Kilo-Byte groß.
Genau, also ein halbes Megabyte für Designable-Nipp und dieses halbe Megabyte ist einfach mal weg. Und das ist für jedes von diesen einzelnen Nipps und das ist gerade nur eine Sprache, die du dir anguckst.
Und im Augenblick wird diese Designable-Nipp aber noch ganz, ganz dringend gebraucht oder ist das eigentlich nur so?
Nee, hast du den Interface-Bilder bei dir drauf auf dem Rechner? Dann mach mal einen Doppelklick auf so einen Nipp-File und dann siehst du, du könntest jetzt, wenn du wolltest, von Mail-App irgendwie, weiß nicht, bestimmte Fenster könntest du dir Größe machen oder den Text ändern oder was auch immer, den Font, Größe, farbig. Also du kannst im Design von den Programmen rumspielen. Solange du nicht irgendwelche Verbindungen änderst, weil die braucht das Programm, aber so Positionen und so sollte dem Programm ziemlich wurscht sein. Dann kannst du jetzt hier klicken, musst du danach nicht speichern. Hier sind wir zum Beispiel im...
Mit dem Interface-Bilder haben wir wahrscheinlich alle schon mal...
Für den Filter sind wir hier gerade, siehste? Und da könntest du jetzt das Fenster größer machen zum Beispiel. Und das geht mit dem Snow Leopard nicht mehr. Weil dir das Art Source-Code vom GUI fehlt. Was aber nicht schlimm ist, weil da geht eh keiner ran und eigentlich hatte auch keiner was dran zu suchen.
Früher hab ich das gerne mal gemacht, um Programme ein bisschen zu verhübschen. Also mit ResEdit damals noch hieß das.
Es hat mich eigentlich wundert, dass Apple das überhaupt mitliefert, dass man da dran rumforschen kann. Aber jetzt sparen sie es halt ein und der ganze Application-Order ist um mehrere hundert Megabyte kleiner geworden.
Verstehe ich das jetzt falsch? Also könnte ich jetzt theoretisch schon jetzt diese Datei einfach löschen von meinem Rechner?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Also könnte man das eigentlich mal ausprobieren, indem man einfach mal irgendwo einen Rechner aufsetzt und damals alles, was die Seine bekommt, nippelt?
Ich kann dir sagen, was bei Leopard dann sofort im Arsch ist. Du brichst das Codesigning aller Applikationen, die gesigned sind.
Okay, das ist ein Grund?
Meinst du?
Hast du schon gelesen? Ich weiß nicht, was signen denn alles?
Ich hab als ich Leopard installiert habe, wollte ich natürlich gleich wieder diese Services-Shortcuts ausschalten. Das schlechteste Feature an Mac OS X. Und damit habe ich mir dann eben meinen Mail-Up gebrochen, was dann nicht mehr in der Lage war, die Passwörter in die Keychain zu packen, weil die Keychain gesagt hat, du bist nicht Mail-Up.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Und da habe ich echt eine Weile gebraucht, bin dann durch irgendeinen Blogpost von jemanden mal drauf gekommen, dass das das Problem ist.
Hörst du, dass du dich eine Sendung so beschwert hast, dass irgendwie den Mail mit der Keychain nicht kaputt ist?
Ja, genau, das war das Problem.
Ich hab immer gesagt, diese scheiß Hacker machen alles kaputt und dann wissen sie nicht, wieso.
Naja, muss ja auch ein bisschen bluten, wisst ihr, wie das ist.
Ja, das muss schon sein.
Aber guck an, auch da findet sich der gelöse.
Designable.nib stirbt.
Wollten wir nicht noch mal ein Thema auf das, von dem ich auch mal ein bisschen Ahnung habe und auf dem man ein bisschen rumhacken kann und wo ihr mich fertig machen wollt?
Kommt noch, kommt noch. Aber wir sind noch ein bisschen in den, wie sagt man, Underpinnings vom US und so.
Jetzt erst mal noch für Erwachsene hier.
Weil ich hab noch eine Ergänzung zu diesem, wie so bei Snow Leopard...
Dafür klau ich mir jetzt noch ein Getränk.
Wie so bei Snow Leopard die Größe noch runterkriegen. Und so hab ich letztens mir auch was angeguckt, wie man dann auf dem iPhone designen soll. Und da waren so Punkte wie mit Stromsparen und Programme kleinhalten und alles in Schnickschnack. Und zwar ist es so, dass auf dem iPhone alle P-Lists, also diese Property-Lists, wo eigentlich was XML ist, dass die nur noch binärformat vorliegen sollen. Oder vorliegen halt, Punkt. Und das gleiche könnte man ja mit Snow Leopard eigentlich auch machen.
Na ja, das ist aber... Darf ich da mal kurz was beschnecken? Also es gibt diese Project... Quatsch, diese, wie heißen die?
P-List.
Die P-List-Dateien. Die Property List, mit denen sämtliche Einstellungen zum Beispiel gespeichert werden.
Sind denn noch so viele in...
Das sind nämlich gar nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viele. Das ist zum Beispiel diese Keyed Objects.
Das ist ein Property List, das heißt ein Text-File. Das heißt diese 8 Kilo Byte kannst du wahrscheinlich nochmal... einen Kilo Byte runter drücken.
Ach echt? Dann machen wir die mal auf, zum Beispiel in BB-Edit.
Ja, zack. So, und jetzt sag mir mal, wie du das wegpacken kannst. Da bleibt dann nichts mehr von übrig.
Aber das sind relativ viele Dateien eigentlich. Stimmt, das ist wirklich...
Guck mal, wie oft das Wort String schon da drin vorkommt.
Ja, ja, nein, das Prinzip ist mir klar. Aber das Binär-Dateien, also das ist das Binär-P-List-Format, das gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten. Ich glaube schon seit 102, Minimum, vielleicht sogar schon seit 10, 1.
Und dass sie es noch nie gemacht haben, meinst du?
Und das wird auch schon für diverse Dateien verwendet.
Das hat damals auch...
Ich hab das ja auch schon gesehen. Deswegen kriegst du ja manche Sachen mit dem hier Text-Edit nicht mehr auf, sondern musstest du dann den Property-List-Editor nehmen. Der, komischerweise, bei Xcode, bei dem neuesten, ist es irgendwie nicht mehr mit dabei. Täusch mich jetzt?
Ich hab hier in Mail-Up mal irgendeinen Keyed-Object-Snip aufgemacht, und das ist auch schon Binär und der Leopard.
Aber noch nicht alles.
Na gut, das mag ja sein. Aber da kann man auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen was mitgeben.
Warte mal, ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass...
Der Property-List-Editor ist noch da, das war ein anderes Tool, was verschwunden ist, ist egal. Die binären Property-List-Files kann man nur mit dem Property-List-Editor aufmachen. Und nicht mehr so einfach.
Ach, guck mal einer an! BB-Edit kann nämlich einfach diese P-List-Dateien aufmachen und ist selber schlau genug, daraus deine Text-Dateien zu machen. Das ist nämlich auch in Wirklichkeit schon eine Binär-Datei.
Ich denke mal, wenn du die Apple-Frameworks, die einen auch mit Property-Lists arbeiten lassen, die werden dir gar nicht mitkriegen, dass es ein binäres ist, sondern es sollte natürlich einfach so funktionieren.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir haben es gerade in BB-Edit nicht mitbekommen.
Was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass man da auch noch weiter die Dateien kleiner kriegt, so wie sie es auf dem iPhone machen.
Ich habe mir noch mal diese... Also auf der Suche nach einer Antwort, wie es das No-Lab-Bot schneller sein kann, gibt es noch ein paar andere Antworten. Also LLVM hatten wir schon. Das andere ist, dass Apple ja offensichtlich vorhat, alles auf 64-Bit zu kompilen.
Zum Beispiel das Mail-App ist auch schon 64-Bit und viele andere Sachen.
Genau, derzeit sind nämlich nur zwei Applikationen auf dem Mac 64-Bit. Die eine habe ich vergessen, die andere war Chess. Und naja, dann gab es irgendwie einen schönen Artikel, wer war das? Ich glaube, da Roughly Drafted, der mal so ein bisschen auseinanderklamm büsert hat.
In letzter Zeit klaut er ganz schön viel und ist ganz schön doll am Spekulieren, finde ich. Hat ganz schön qualitätsmäßig nachgelassen, finde ich.
Wie auch immer, eine exzellente Source ist es immer noch. Was mir selber nicht so klar war, ist, wie katastrophal das bei Vista mit dem 64-Bit tatsächlich ist.
Es kommt drauf an, welche Version du hast.
Ja, aber sehr.
Von den 40 verschiedenen, weil du brauchst ja irgendwie...
Genau, sie haben halt dieses LLP 64 sich für entschieden, während alle anderen LP 64 machen.
Ja, die hatten ja irgendwelche komischen Gründe, warum was wie kompatibler sein sollte, aber alle anderen großen Firmen, Sun und Apple, HP und die Linux Distributes usw. nehmen alle LP 64 und nur Microsoft nimmt was anderes.
Ja, deswegen haben sie auch nicht so viele Speedgains, weil erst in diesem LP 64 kannst du dann eben so richtig machen. Aber das ist halt auch der Grund. Allein dadurch, dass sie alles auf 64-Bit kompilen, wird es schneller, weil der 64-Bit-Modus, dieser AMD 64-Bit-Modus mehr Register bereitstellt.
Unter anderem. Das ist erstmal so von der Hardware-Seite. Was denn noch? Na, der das schön an den 64-Bit ist, natürlich kommt ja noch die Geschichte mit dem Mehrspeicher, aber das lassen wir jetzt merken, das ist ja eigentlich klar, dass Apple halt keine Rückwärtskompatibilität beachten muss. Und deswegen haben sie ihre Function-Calls, werden jetzt nicht mehr auf den Stack abgelegt, die Parameter, sondern in diesen zusätzlichen Registern halt. Und das ist ja, wie sagt man, damit würden sie ja sonst die ABI brechen, nehme ich mal an. Und hier können sie erstmal noch das Handeln, wie sie wollen. Und, war es das schon? Hatt ich noch was? Verdammt. Aber das ist eine der großen Geschichten auch, warum es schneller wird, weil sie halt einfach die Strukturen noch ein bisschen ändern können, so wie es mit 32bit nicht gegangen wäre.
Sie müssen eigentlich gar nicht an ihre eigenen Programme ran. Sie müssen ihre Programme nicht schneller schreiben, sondern sie machen einfach alles darunter schneller.
Genau.
Was auch ein bisschen schade ist. Aber vielleicht waren die Programme ja schon immer schnell.
Eigentlich ist es so, sie können jetzt halt mit dem, also sagen wir das Mail-App, sie schreiben es gar nicht neu oder um, wenn man es Standard-Mail-App jetzt mal so nimmt, den Code. Sie können den gleichen Code jetzt mit LLVM kompilieren, dadurch wird es ein Stück schneller. Und dann das Ganze noch, ich weiß gar nicht, ob bei LLVM jetzt auch schon LLVM 64-Bit macht, ich denke mal schon. Also wenn sie LLVM benutzen und 64-Bit, müsste es alleine dadurch schon 40% schneller werden. Weiß ich nicht, also ohne was zu tun.
Wenn ich Mac OS 10 im Quellcode vorliegen hätte, könnte ich jetzt auf der Stelle mir eine doppelt so schnelle Mac OS Version passen?
Du musst einfach nur Snow Lapper benutzen, das flutscht alles wie nichts.
Das wäre, glaubt man, ein Versuch Snow Lappert mal sich aufzubesorgen.
Aber das ist ja verboten.
Das ist verboten, stimmt. In der Bucht treibt eins rum.
In der Bucht treibt eins rum? War das ein Wink mit dem Soundfall?
Ja, ein Schlager.
Naja, ich denke, es gab da noch so ein paar andere Details, was da noch alles irgendwie neu kommt. Ich meine, sie aktualisieren natürlich auch ihre Subsysteme, Kubs und den ganzen Kram, aber so ehrlich gesagt, habe ich da nicht viel Neues gelesen.
Das hat Apple inzwischen auch komplett eingekauft, habe ich letztens gelesen. Weil früher war es ja nur lizenziert und dann irgendwann haben sie das Ganze gekauft.
Die haben den Developer gekauft. Das ist ja im Wesentlichen auch nur ein Mann. Das Kubs-Projekt läuft genauso bei Apple wie eben so viele andere Open-Source-Projekte auch. Also mittlerweile ist Apple auch ein extremer Kontributor. Also gerade bei diesem Kubs ist es wohl so, dass 40% des Codes, der zu Kubs beigesteuert wird, kommt mittlerweile von Apple und 60% kommt von der Community. Oder 30-70% sowas, in der Größenordnung war es.
Wenn ich kurz mal...
Kubs allerdings könnte auch mal echt auf Version 3.0 springen. Jetzt sind sie glaube ich, 1.4 ist das nächste. Ich finde, sie sollten die 2.0 gleich überspringen, weil da fehlt mir einfach noch die Stabilität. Ich finde, das Mac OS X, was das Drucken betrifft, Einschränkung, schlechter ist als damals noch unter Mac OS 9.
Immer noch.
Finde ich. Mittlerweile, es hat sich ein bisschen gebessert, aber die Reliability beim Drucken, die ich früher gewohnt war, die ist noch nicht wieder da. Also das ist für mich einfach immer alles noch ein bisschen, du schickst es irgendwo hin und dann kannst du beten.
Also Drucken ist ja sowieso mal, ehrlich gesagt, mein Thema für sich. Ich drucke sehr sehr selten.
Deswegen wahrscheinlich.
Ich drucke hier jeden Tag und ich kann dir sagen, ich liebe es, wenn es Rock Solid ist.
Das verstehe ich. Und ich habe neulich irgendwie auf einem HP-Drucker drucken wollen. Und ich dachte, ich stecke einfach nur diesen Drucker an per USB und alles ist super. Nein, ich konnte noch auf die Seite von HP gehen. Mittlerweile ist er glaube ich im Betriebssystem dabei, aber damals war er es noch nicht. Duft mir 160 Megabyte Daten runterladen. Treiber durfte Programme installieren. Dufte mein Rechner mehrfach neu starten. Die Kiste war danach nicht instabil, aber langsam, ohne Ende. Sodass ich es dann relativ schnell auch wieder entsorgt habe, weil so oft druck ich wie gesagt nicht. Nur um ein blödes Blatt Papier auszudrucken. Und wenn ich denke, jede Scheiß-Digital-Kamera nehme ich, stecke sie an, sind alle Fotos drauf, ein iPhoto, ohne dass ich irgendwie mit der Wimper zuckere, äh Zucker, Zucker und Zuckere.
Ja, deine Fotos haben ja auch keine Fonds.
Oh, aber eigentlich so ein Punkt. Es sollte doch, also ich glaube das ist eine Frage der, weil die Druckerindustrie schon so unglaublich alt ist, können die sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass es eine Zeit geben könnte, in der man keine Druckertreiber braucht, bloß um irgendwie Text auf Papier zu kriegen. Wenn der Drucker heute erfunden worden wäre, dann würde jedes Betriebssystem damit umgehen können, weil dann würden sie sich relativ schnell auf einen Standard einigen und dann ginge das einfach.
Und so ist es. Man braucht eigentlich auch gar keine Druckertreiber. Das ist halt auch genau der Irrsinn. Und gerade so etwas wie 160 MB von HP runterladen, das ist komplett irren. Bei diesem Teil, was ich da habe, ich habe einen HP LaserJet 3055 und ich kann viel Gutes sagen über dieses Gerät.
Der hat vier Stockwerke oder wie viel sind das?
Das ist halt so ein Kombi-Teil, Scanner, Fax und so weiter. Funktioniert eigentlich super. Hardware-mäßig muss ich auch sagen, hat HP das irgendwie raus. Die haben jetzt lange noch das gebaut, das funktioniert. Das kommt dann so an die Reliability ran, die ich so vom Apple Laser weiter gewohnt war.
Das sind nicht die schönsten Geräte, aber auf jeden Fall sind sie relativ okay.
Das Problem ist natürlich, dass wenn du solche Spezialfunktionen hast, wie kann-scannen.
Klar, dann hat man sowieso ein Problem.
Scanner-Infrastruktur unter Mac OS X finde ich ist noch schlimmer, immer noch.
Die ist wirklich feuchtbar.
Die ist richtig grauenhaft, aber auch das hat viel mit den Herstellern zu tun, weil es gibt immerhin ein Subsystem, das benutzt bloß keiner. Aber was halt einfach immer wieder störend ist, ist, dass der eigentliche Druckzuleitungsprozess so intransparent ist. Vollkommen unabhängig von dem Druckertreiber. Wenn ich was drucke, und das ist in der Queue, warum sehe ich das Dokument nicht in der Queue? Da steht, ich drucke 10 Seiten, dass der Job ist, weil der Drucker ausgeschaltet wird auf Hold und ich weiß nicht mehr, was das ist. Der heißt dann irgendwie Applikationsname.nnnnn, vielleicht Name des Dokumentes. Aber ich kann da nicht doppelklicken und drauf gucken, was das ist. Ich kann auch nicht sagen, halt mal an, nimm mal die Seite raus, die drucke man nicht und so weiter. Wo ist da einfach die Flexibilität? Ich vermisse das.
Das ist wirklich was Wahres.
Wie auch immer, wir sind noch unzufrieden.
Habt ihr eigentlich von diesem Ruby-Exploit was gelesen?
Ruby-Exploit?
Da gab es ja hier so einen Ruby-Bug oder sechs Stück gerade, wo sie überall Ruby patchen müssen.
Ruby generell?
Also ich hatte irgendwie so einen Apple-Security-Guy gefunden, da mussten sie erstmal ganzen Rubys reparieren gehen.
Also was ich jetzt gehört habe, dass man relativ leicht mit, dass der Apple Remote Desktop Agent unsicher ist und es zulässt, dass man, da komm ich gleich noch kurz drauf, dass man Apple-Skripte mit Routerechten ausführen kann und über Apple-Rechte ohne dass eine Passwortabfrage kommt.
Hab ich auch gelesen, aber hab ich mich ein wenig weiter gekümmert.
Ja, ist halt so das alte Problem von Set-User-ID-Prozessen. Da müssen sie halt mal ran.
Und das ist nicht so ganz ohne das Problem.
Das heißt, man macht demnächst Fixed Permissions mit einem Disk-Utility und dann ist alles wieder okay?
Wahrscheinlich wird es noch eine Sicherheitslösung von Apple geben.
Nee, du kannst halt einfach diesen Prozess, wenn er läuft, also die kurzfristige Hilfe ist, dass du einfach deinen Remote Administration Feature in Sharing einschaltest.
Genau, das ist das Lustige daran.
Weil wenn der läuft, dann gibt es dieses Problem nicht. Warum kann ich dir das gerade nicht erklären?
Also man muss entfernte Verwaltung in Sharing einschalten, um sicher zu sein. Also genau das Gegenteil von dem, was man eigentlich erwarten würde.
Das solltest du auch mal ändern, weil ich hab da gerne alle Buttons aus eigentlich.
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen, dass du da gerne alles aus hast. Das sollte Apple natürlich auch relativ dringend ändern, auf jeden Fall. Was du eben gerade angeguckt hast, das ist nochmal ganz, ganz kurzes Abschweifen, weil ihr gerade so alle auf dem Bildschirm schaut. Ich hab mir ein neues Headset gekauft. Und hab seit gestern ein neues Headset von Sennheiser. Und das ist das erste iPhone-Headset, mit dem ich mich auf Anni verliebt habe.
Das heißt, das erste iPhone-Headset hat das auch so kompatible...
Du meinst, das ist ein Kopfhörer mit normalen Klinkenanschluss. Weil Headset hört sich immer so nach Remote-Bluetooth-Schnickschnack an.
Das Headset heißt, das hat ein Mikrofon.
Genau, das hat ein Mikrofon drin und hat eine kleine Taste, wie die original Apple-Kopphörer. Das ist...
Das ist kompatibel.
Und passt auch ins iPhone.
Es passt auch ins iPhone. Es ist fürs iPhone gemacht, also steht drauf, for iPhone, das ist die Hauptaufgabe, die es hat. Kostet relativ bezahlbare, irgendwie 55 Euro oder so was. Und was für einen guten In-Ear-Kopphörer echt absolut okay ist.
Ja, das Problem ist, so schön die auch sind, die sind halt trotzdem nach zwei, drei Monaten kaputt, weil es einfach so filigranes Zeug ist.
Das sind immer noch so Dinge, die man sich ins Ohr stecken muss, ne? Das hasse ich ja.
Ich mag das total.
Ich hab mal welche so benutzt oder mir probiert von anderen Leuten. Der Bass ist schon echt schicker mit diesen Kopfhörern, aber ich finde, die halten immer nicht so ewig. Alle halbe Jahre brauch ich neue Kopfhörer, weil die irgendwann zerreißen, Kabelbruch oder irgendwas passiert.
Das ist immer mein Problem. Das tut weh.
Also es gibt hier verschiedene große Ohreinsätze dafür.
Aber ich bin schon erstaunt, dass es so ein Produkt überhaupt gibt.
Es gibt von diversen Herstellern iPhone-Headsets solcher Art, also die auf die offizielle Klinke oben drauf passen und die dann auch ein kleines Mikro drin haben.
Was heißt denn genau iPhone-Headset?
Dass es reinpasst, weil der Anschluss ist ja so eng.
Das heißt, dass es reinpasst, das heißt, dass es ein Mikro hat, das heißt, dass ich darüber telefonieren kann. Es hat diesen Button, mit dem ich das Telefonat annehmen kann und auflegen kann.
Wie funktioniert denn dieser Button?
Ich hab keinen blasser Schimmer, indem ich drauf drücke.
Naja, aber...
Die haben eine Leitung mehr als das iPhone.
Also die haben sicher? Hier an dem Stecker ist eine Leitung mehr dran.
Also die ist natürlich auch für das Mikro da. Für das Mikro da, die Einleitung. Was sie genau mit dem Rücken dann machen.
Ja, genau. Ich denke, der Druckknopf, das ist bestimmt irgendwie so eine In-Band-Signalisierungsgeschichte.
Und es gibt ganz unglaublich teure Headsets fürs iPhone. Und das ist, wie gesagt, für 56 Euro relativ günstig. Das Original von Apple kostet 25 Euro. Das geht, glaube ich, im Dreiminutentakt kaputt. Also davon hab ich mittlerweile vier oder fünf verschleißt. Aber so normalerweise, so in ihr Kopfhörer oder Kopfhörer halten bei mir doch... Ich gehe halbwegs pfleglich mit denen um, doch schon ein bisschen länger.
Sennheiser Communications MM50 für iPhone. Der Tipp der Woche.
Also wie gesagt, und ich find's sehr angenehm, die ich vorher hatte, die waren extrem schwer, die Kopfhörer. Also das Headset, das war... Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der herstellt.
Okay, wo wir gerade dann bei Produktempfehlungen sind. Und uns von unseren schönen, komplizierten, erwachsenen Technik-Themen abbringst.
Also Snow Leopard, waren wir erstmal fertig, oder?
Ja, dann kann ich hier auch gleich mal mein neues Gadget auf the Week zeigen. Ich habe mir tatsächlich eine Rechner-Tasche gekauft. Ich dachte ja nicht, dass das noch passieren wird in diesem Jahrtausend. Aber ich habe dann endlich was gefunden. Und zwar ein Produkt fort. Und ich kaufe mir wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein zweites. Das erzähle ich gleich. Man mag es nicht glauben. Von Logitech, aber gebaut von Axio. Und Axio sind die mit den coolen Motorrad-Teilen, wo du davon geschwärmt hast. Die verkaufen ja primär über den Motorradhandel. Die haben halt auch mit diesen aerodynamischen extra Huppeln oben drauf. Nicht ausschließlich. Die haben auch gesehen, dass sie im Laptop-Markt jetzt durchaus gefragt sind. Aber der Vertrieb in Deutschland stinkt halt immer noch. Du kriegst halt Axio einfach nirgends.
Falls ich mal zwischendurch kurz die Kurzkritik abgeben darf. Ich glaube, ich hätte es mir nicht gekauft. In meiner Welt ist es nicht unbedingt hundertprozentig. Aber jetzt erst mal weiter.
Muss es ja auch nicht sein. Optisch meinst du jetzt?
Genau.
Optisch, optisch.
Ist das denn ein Rucksack oder eine Tasche?
Also jetzt erstmal, worum es hier geht. Die Produkt-Serie heißt Logitech Kinetik. Und es gibt da genau zwei Modelle. Das eine ist eine Tasche, das andere ist ein Rucksack. Und der Rucksack sieht eben sehr aus wie diese Axio Rucksäcke. Und so musst du den fotografieren. Und das ist halt das Coole. Das Ding hat halt in der Mitte die Aufnahmetasche für den Rechner. Und da passt noch so ein bisschen Tünnef mit rein. Und dann hat es halt außen so zwei Schalen, die mit einem Reißverschluss so drauf gemacht werden, die aufklappen, sodass man da eben auch ordentlich rankommt. Und es hat viele kleine Taschen für Zeug. Und dann ist hier eine große Tasche für Kopfhörer drin. So kann ich jetzt immer einen Kopfhörer mit dabei haben. Dann habe ich hier so eine Tasche für so Climbim Fernbedienung, USB-Adapter. Dann habe ich eine für das Netzteil.
Da sind überall so kleine Eikens dran, so wie beide Tiefkühltruhe im Tiefkühlschrank. Was passt da rein?
Wofür es gedacht ist?
Also das ist für Webcam, Maus oder USB-Stick. Das da ist für...
Genau, das hier ist so die Technik-Seite mit diesen großen Taschen. Und hier nochmal so ein Netz, von dem du sicher sein willst, dass du sie dabei hast, weil du sie sonst nicht immer dabei hast, reintun kannst. Und dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen die Büro-Seite, wo du halt so Stiftfach, Kreditkarten, Schnickschnack, Handy-Tasche, wenn es sein muss. Und nochmal so ein paar Zipper-Teile und so, wo man filigranen Klangkabel reinschmeißen kann.
Okay, aber das kleine Rucksack ist eine Tasche.
Genau, aber gibt es auch als Rucksack mit demselben Prinzip. Und der hat dann auch noch den Vorteil, dass er in diesem Gurt noch eine iPod-Tasche hat. Du hast hier so einen kleinen Zipper im Gurt. Du kannst ein iPod reinmachen mit einem Loch für das Kabel raus für Kopfhörer. Sehr schick. Und im Prinzip ein ähnliches Angebot, nur dass so diese ganz große Tasche für Kopfhörer da nicht dabei ist, aber dafür hast du ein bisschen mehr Platz noch in dem Rucksack, um so Zeug zu machen. Also ich würde sagen, wer mit Rucksäcken gut leben kann oder für den das eh besser ist, und der mehr Platz für Klamotten braucht, und wer so mehr auf Tasche steht, ist das. Aber ich tendiere dazu, mir den Rucksack auch noch mit dazu zu holen. Weil es billig, kostet nur 79 Euro.
79 Euro, das ist echt okay.
Und es ist ordentlich verarbeitet, und vor allem die Dinger klappen halt auf, du kommst richtig ran, du siehst, was drin ist, und es kann halt nicht...
Also ich hab ja eben gerade so ein Negativ-Kritisch, was das Aussehen angeht. Also ich finde die Verarbeitung hier von diesen ganzen Haken und sowas, finde ich sehr schick. Ich mag dieses Hartschalen, das ist so ein Hartschalenzeug, oder?
Nö, das ist eine Weichschale.
Aber das ist kein Stoff auf jeden Fall.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen verhärtet, ja. Aber soll ja auch, weil es soll ja ein bisschen...
Nein, es hat halt so ein bisschen Standstabilität. Es ist jetzt nicht Schlagstabilität. Es ist einfach, dass es so ein bisschen formstabil ist.
Also es sieht schon so ein bisschen seriöser aus.
Wie ich.
Du bist seriös?
Nee, ich sehe seriöser aus.
So, als ich... oder als...
Weiß ich nicht, als ich bin.
Gut, dann weiter in der Sendung?
So, ja, was haben wir denn noch?
Nein, bleib mal bei den Kinderthemen. Kinderthemen? Kinderthemen.
Firefox 3 gibt es ja jetzt.
Genau.
Wobei, ich hab ja lieber Safari Fox 4.
Ja, Firefox 3. Ich hab nicht viel Zeit darauf verwendet, das Ding zu testen, aber ich hab festgestellt, dass es immer noch nicht das macht, was ich will und hab es wieder beendet.
Squirrel Fish hatten wir vor zwei Wochen schon, ne?
Ja.
Also ich für meinen Teil muss sagen, ich hab Firefox noch nie sonderlich gemocht. Also Firefox 2 war mir immer zu langsam, immer zu wenig Mac-like und... Damals hab ich immer Safari benutzt. Safari wurde mir irgendwann mal zu langsam, eine Zeit lang hab ich so schnell OmniWeb benutzt. Dann war ich lange Zeit sehr, sehr glücklich mit Camino, weil das eigentlich ein schöner, schneller Browser ist, der einen Flashblocker drin hat. Und liebe Leute, wenn ihr viele Tabs offen habt, ein Flashblocker ist unglaublich wichtig, weil damit habt ihr 70 Tabs offen und euer Rechner, es geht nicht gleich komplett in die Knie.
50 Prozent weniger CPU-Verbrauch, weniger Lüfter anschmeißen.
Genau, das ist unglaublich. Also ein Flashblocker ist das, was ich bei Safari am meisten vermisse eigentlich. Überhaupt ein Adblocker.
Ein Flashblocker, der einfach explizit alles, was Flash ist, auch wenn es sinnvoll ist, erstmal nicht startet.
Genau, sondern erst, wenn ich draufklicke.
Ein Adblocker hätte ich da auch gerne.
Das ist aber noch viel sinnvoller als ein Adblocker, weil meistens sind die Ads sowieso alle Flash.
Genau. Und damit wird einfach der Rechner viel schneller. Und dann war ich mit Camino soweit relativ glücklich. Und jetzt habe ich mir schon vor einiger Zeit mal Firefox 3 angeguckt, als es in die Beta-Phase ging. Und ja, ich mag den Browser extrem gerne. Zum einen ist er wirklich sehr, sehr schnell geworden mit der neuen Version. Läuft bei mir ziemlich stabil. Also die Beta-Version nicht ganz so, jetzt die finale Version läuft erstaunlich schnell. Und es gibt zwar, das glaubt man immer nicht, aber es gibt doch sehr, sehr viele kleine, schicke Plugins, die einem das Leben doch ein bisschen einfacher machen. Und so alles in allem führte das jetzt dazu, dass ich mittlerweile tatsächlich umgestiegen bin und die ganze Zeit mit Firefox rumsurfe.
Unterstützt aber immer noch nicht die Keychain.
Es unterstützt noch. Die Mac-Likey-NOS könnte ruhig noch ein bisschen besser sein. Es könnte ein bisschen besser sein.
Das ist einfach ein OS neben dem OS.
Mir war das Rollen zu rucklig irgendwie.
Es ist besser geworden mit drei.
Ist besser geworden heißt aber, sie haben nichts Substantielles geändert. Sie haben nichts Substantielles geändert. Sie malen immer noch alle ihre Widgets selber und versuchen so ein bisschen auszusehen, wie gerade so das, was sie so glauben, wie ein Leopard aussieht, anstatt das Leopard einfach selber malen zu lassen. Nichts ist nativ, weil sie haben so ein Detail, was...
Die werden erstmal ein Problem haben, wenn die bei Apple ihr Boy ändern.
Textediting funktioniert jetzt genauso.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Die Widgets sind ziemlich sicher nativ, die man sieht. Nein, sind sie nicht. Mit Firefox 3?
Das ist alles selbstgemalt.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass nicht.
Ich weiß es, weil ich es gelesen hab. Da hat ja einer komplett darüber abgeratet, dass es so ist. Dann hat sich da in dem Blog sogar noch der Firefox-Entwickler selber dazu geäußert, warum sie das machen.
Die Buttons, die ich in der Seite sehe, sind der Rollbalken zum Beispiel, das ist doch ein Mac OS Rahlbalken, den ich hier gerade vor mir habe.
Na, der sieht jetzt so aus wie ein Mac OS. Ja, so sieht jetzt so aus. Aber ich sagte ja, sobald Schnee-Leo den 3D-Ligmi-Look abgelöst hat gegen was anderes, dann sieht das hier immer noch genauso aus.
Snow-Leo-Balken werden bestimmt genau so aussehen wie das Herzige.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Und noch ist es so.
Ich hoffe, auch die Scroll-Balken von iTunes sind schick. Die finde ich gut. Kannst du mir erzählen, was du willst? Firefox ist einfach neben der Spur. Ja, aber man kann die Passwörter nicht in der Keychain ablegen. Ich meine, damit ist der Browser unbenutzbar.
Damit ist er nicht unbenutzbar, sondern...
Wo legen Sie denn bitte die Passwörter ab?
Ist mir relativ wurscht, dass es ein schöner Browser ist.
Ist dir egal. Es sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie Klartext-Files, die auf deinem Desktop liegen. Naja, aber ich meine, wo?
Irgendwo in meinem Profile-Ordner.
Genau, in irgendeinem Cache-File oder so. Ich finde das unseriös. Ich meine, was hält Sie bitte davon ab, das zu unterstützen?
Weil es auf allen anderen Plattformen auch in dem VCR-Ordner, Profile-Ordner liegt, deswegen.
Ach, Sie haben doch auf jeder Plattform auch plattformspezifisches Zeug. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass dieses Teil jetzt überhaupt nicht mit dem Betriebssystem zusammenarbeitet.
Also ich meine, der Browser ist schon, also Firefox ist schon sehr stark ans Betriebssystem angepasst. Auch was das Theme angeht, das Aussehen, das...
Das ist alles nachprogrammiert. Ich meine, wenn das jeder machen würde, dann hätte ich, das ist wie es bei Windows ist.
Was, wie es bei Windows ist?
Na ja, wo jeder irgendwie versucht, irgendeinen Look zu erzeugen.
Aber Apple macht das auch alle dreieinhalb Minuten. Na ganz im Ernst, also ich meine, welche Widgets sind der Standard-Widget? Wenn du Final Cut startest, dann hast du ein, das ist das Gesamt-iTunes, um jetzt nochmal auf das Thema, klar, da ist es ein Grund zum Meckern.
Final Cut ist ja auch gekauft, da können wir nichts dafür.
Ich meine, wir können eigentlich jedes beliebige iWork oder iLive-Programm nehmen, die haben alle, mindestens teilweise Elemente.
Ja, aber da kann ich zumindest mit Tab über meine User-Interface-Elemente rüber tabben in einem Dialog. Das geht halt einfach bei Firefox. Nein, ich tab und nichts passiert. So und ich bin einfach...
Okay, dann hast du sowieso immer abgeschaltet.
Ja und ich hab das sowieso immer eingeschaltet und deswegen fallen solche Programme bei mir einfach sofort raus, wenn die einfach nicht die OS X... Wie soll ich es dann benutzen? Ich benutze alle Programme so und dieses Programm kann man nicht so benutzen. Ja, finde ich auch langweilig, Firefox 3.
Nee, ist schon okay. Kann man halt manche Sachen, die bei Safari nicht gehen, kann man es halt benutzen.
Firefox 3 ist super, wenn man spezielle Plugins hat und es ist super, wenn man Windows hat.
Und Linux ist auch super. Und auf dem Mac ist es ein schneller Browser. Deutlich schneller als Scheiß Safari.
Oh, mein Schild ruft hier auch noch einer an. Ich muss mal die Nachtschaltung einschalten. Zack.
Klingelt bestimmt gleich nochmal.
Jetzt klingelt das Telefon da hinten, oder das hab ich direkt an ISDN. Scheiße. Sonst ruft nie einer an bei meinen Podcasts.
Tja, wir brauchen hier so eine Sekretärin.
Also, um es mal kurz zu machen, Firefox 3 ist ein sehr, sehr schneller Browser, viel schneller als Safari, stürzt nicht so oft ab.
Ist doch auch nicht schneller als Safari.
Da bläst der schneller als Safari.
Nein.
Das ist schon Firefox 2. Das mag sein, das sind irgendwelche Benchmarks.
Aber mal ehrlich, ob der Browser jetzt für Spiegel irgendwie 2,5 Sekunden braucht oder 2,7?
Nein, wie gesagt, genau diese Problematik, wenn ich 70 Tabs offen habe, und ich hab immer 70 Tabs offen, wie viel Rechenzeit braucht dann der Safari? Und mit Vergleich zum Firefox, zugegebenermaßen mit einem Flashblocker drin. Und da ist einfach mal Firefox ein kleiner Browser, der im Hintergrund rumliegt und sich lang...
Firefox ist doch nicht klein, das ist doch riesengroß.
Ja, also was die Prozessorlast angeht.
Na wohl, Firefox ist auch nur 45 MB groß. Ich glaub, das ist der Safari sogar größer inzwischen, oder? Na Safari 60 MB groß.
Aber das wird sich mit Snow Leopard alles ändern.
Es sind bestimmt die ganzen vielen Sprachen hier mit...
Pass auf der Platte.
Aber auch im Speicher, ich weiß ja nicht. Ich starte jetzt einfach mal beide.
Und? Computer ist abgestürzt.
Ist das dann überhaupt eine halbwegs aktuelle Version, die du da hast? Oder ist es noch wie Zweier?
Das ist topaktuell. Denn es fällt nur topaktuelles Zeug.
Ich wollte mal gucken. Ich würde ja schon mal mit dem nächsten Thema anfangen.
Oh, das ist tatsächlich eine aktuelle Version. Das sind die drei.
Achso, habe ich extra besorgt. Ich dachte, du meinst jetzt was anderes. So, nun werden wir jetzt mal hier gucken, wie viel der Speicherverbrauch ist. Von zwei Browsern, die jeweils kein Windows offen haben, also gar nichts angesurft haben. Dann haben wir bei Firefox, also bei Safari haben wir 65 MB verbraucht und bei Firefox 42. Also tatsächlich auf dünnerem Fuß. Eis oder wie auch immer. Nee, Eis nicht. So, ich mache mal bei beiden Spiegel.
Spiegel?
Ja, so als Seite halt. Und dann gucken wir mal dann, wie der Verbrauch ist. Aus Speed ist mir jetzt erstmal egal. Dann geht Firefox auf 67 MB hoch und Safari auf 70 MB. Na okay.
Vergleichbar.
Naja, aber ich würde sagen, wenn ich jetzt noch eine Seite aufmache, dann hat ja Firefox den Safari auch schon eingeholt. Aber okay, ich meine, wir streiten uns auch hier irgendwie, ob der eine lieber Spaghetti mag oder der andere lieber irgendwie Spätzle. Das ist einfach mal egal.
Ja, also Firefox 3 ist ein schöner Browser, der sehr viel schneller ist als Firefox 2, den ich nie gemocht habe.
Firefox 2, wir sind inzwischen bei Firefox 3.1. 11, nee 3.1.
Nee, 3.
3.0.
3.1. Da kam doch letztes Update. 3.1 sind wir. Guck nach.
Was, letztens?
Ja, vor ein paar Wochen.
Erst vor ein paar Tagen ist 3.0 released worden.
Achso, nein Safari, Entschuldigung.
Achso, du redest von mir.
Genau, Firefox 2 konnte ich nie leiden, aber Firefox 3 ist ein sehr schöner Browser, auch auf dem Mac, egal was Tim sagt.
Das hast du jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Und guck den nochmal an.
Ja, ich benutze den einfach aus einem Grund nicht. Er verhält sich nicht wie eine Macintosh.
Das hatten wir jetzt alles schon noch einmal. Nächste Thema.
Soll ich es nochmal sagen?
Nee, nächste Thema.
Nächste Thema ist Sprout Core.
Verhält sich das wie eine Mac OS Applikation?
Deine Ecke jetzt, aber ich denke mal du weißt von nichts.
Doch, ich weiß, ich weiß wovon. Sprout Core ist das, ist ein JavaScript-Framework, mit dem man User-Interfaces nachbilden kann. In HTML, damit das Web so ein bisschen aussieht wie eine Desktop-Applikation. Und das ist das, was Apple jetzt ganz großartig einsetzt bei den ganzen neuen tollen Mobile-Me-Applikationen.
Hat das deine Hausaufgaben gemacht?
Absolut.
Mehr aber nicht. Ich hab mich leider noch nicht damit beschäftigt. Ich hab's noch nicht installiert, mal Probehalber. Hab mir das mal vorgenommen, aber die letzten Wochen waren so stressig, dass ich das leider gar dafür keine Zeit hatte.
Ja, nachdem Apple auf der WWDC da auch einen Vortrag zu gemacht hat.
Der Vortrag war highly guarded. Also ganz doll abgeschoben, sollte keiner was wissen.
Was natürlich bei einem Open Source Projekt ein bisschen schwierig ist, weil das steht ja sozusagen alles im Internet und das ist ja auch nichts Neues. Neu ist eigentlich nur, dass Apple da so drauf setzt und dass sie eben jetzt ihre ganzen Mobile-Me-Anwendungen damit selber entwickelt. Und sie haben ja auch das Team gekauft. Also sie haben die Bude gekauft, dieses proudit.com. Die sind glaube ich so zwei Leute oder drei, keine Ahnung, wenige auf jeden Fall, die das gehackt haben. Und die haben ja auch schon eine relativ erfolgreiche Anwendung damit selber realisiert. Also das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so ein Framework, sondern das Framework ist so ein bisschen wie die Geschichte bei Ruby on Rails. Sie wollten da mal eine Anwendung schreiben, haben festgestellt, dass sie nicht das passende Framework dafür haben. Dann haben sie das Framework halt auch nochmal erzeugt. Die Anwendung heißt Mailroom. Mailroom wird übrigens sowohl bei der Obama-Präsidential-Campaign eingesetzt, als auch bei McCain.
Oh, McCain wird auf jeden Fall das Tool des Präsidenten.
Bitte?
Jaja klar, die Logos sehen sich auch durchaus ähnlich.
Das ist das Lustige daran.
Der Nachgeschmack ist auch glaube ich vergleichbar. Mailroom ist auf jeden Fall so eine Anwendung, mit der man halt Mail lesen kann im Browser. Ich habe damit jetzt nicht so viel mit rumgespielt, aber was jetzt auch nochmal deutlich wurde, ist Apple mag Sprout Core, weil es ein ähnliches Programmieren ist, wie mit Coco. Das heißt, das Sprout Core Framework folgt demselben Paradigma von Model View Controller, ist aber eine JavaScript-Variante. Das ist halt alles JavaScript und soweit ich das verstanden habe, ist es halt auch sehr JavaScript-y. Es gibt da ja auch noch so ein anderes Projekt von, hab ich jetzt vergessen, 280 Grad irgendwas, die so mit Objective-J dahergehen und die halt tatsächlich versuchen, so ein bisschen Objective-C in JavaScript sozusagen nachzubilden. In JavaScript. Und halt dasselbe da probieren.
Da kommt sie dann mit dem Skrill-Fish irgendwie passen, dass sie ihre JavaScript-Engine gerade im Safari getauscht haben, weil die ist ja dann auch nicht nur im Safari getauscht, sondern in allem, was irgendwie auf dem OS X irgendwie darstellt.
Ja, man kann festhalten, JavaScript ist für Apple eine strategische Plattform. Sonst würden sie da nicht so viel Intentivität... Das ist natürlich klar, weil es das Web ist, aber es geht auch einfach übers Web hinaus.
Also die erste Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, als ich das gelesen habe mit Sproutcore, Apple wird ja da tierisch viele Anpassungen gemacht haben an diesem Toolkit, damit es wirklich schön nativ, wie es Mac OS aussieht. Damit die MobileMe, damit sich der übliche Mac-Anwender, der typische in seinen MobileMe Anwendungen auch schön wohlführt. Ich habe ja die stille Hoffnung, dass diese Änderungen, die sie da gemacht haben, dass die auch wieder veröffentlicht werden. Weil das würde mir als Web-Entwickler ermöglichen, Netz-Applikationen zu entwickeln, die aussehen wie Mac-Applikationen, was natürlich, wie wir alle wissen, die schönsten Applikationen überhaupt sind.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass das Frameback optisch so festgenagelt ist, oder?
Ja, aber die Änderung, die Apple da gemacht hat, damit es Mac-like aussieht, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich vermute das. Da hatten sie jetzt wenig Grund, da nicht ihre Änderungen, ich meine, die Leute, die das machen, die arbeiten für Apple und der Deal war, ihr könnt hier weitermachen.
So macht Apple das ja immer. Die kaufen die Leute ein, indem sie sagen, du kriegst deinen Job bei uns.
So machen sie es mit Kubs. All diese ganzen Projekte, die wir eben schon behandelt haben, LLVM, das sind alles Projekte, die nach wie vor...
Ja, aber auf dieses Seam, wahrscheinlich ist dieses Sprout Core Seamable, geh ich mal von außen, hab ich mich noch nicht mit beschäftigt, aber... Ob dieses Seam, was das so aussehen lässt, wie Leopard...
Werden wir sehen. Die eigentliche Frage ist, die ich mir stelle, was ist jetzt die Strategie dahinter? Also warum legt Apple so viel Wert da drauf und warum pushen sie bei ihrer Developer-Konferenz explizit, dass die Entwickler das sozusagen auch wissen und vielleicht sogar auch benutzen? Was ist der Hintergrund? Erstmal, das Feld, was jetzt hier aufgestoßen wird, ist im Prinzip die... Jetzt haben wir es. Es ist Web 3.0. Ja, ist ja nun ein Witz. Was ich meine ist, wir reden jetzt hier von rich clients. Wir reden von Anwendungen, die in JavaScript geschrieben sind, die im Browser laufen, bzw. im Web-Engine. Und die vollständigen Applikationen sind, die offline arbeiten können. Die letzten Änderungen am WebKit, im Safari-WebKit, waren ja unter anderem auch lokales Speichern von Daten. Du hast dann irgendwie lokal... Local Storage, du kannst da irgendwie lokal mit deinem SQLite sprechen und so ne Sachen. Und das ermöglicht das Herunterladen von Anwendungen per Web, die danach gar keine Internetverbindungen mehr brauchen. Heute haben wir ja eben in dieser 2.0-Generation eben haben wir Rich Clients, die aber vor allem mit einem noch sehr viel reicheren Server-Backend reden. Und dort ist die ganze Funktionalität und über Ajax und diese ganzen anderen Funktionalitäten. Genau, die nachladen und die das brauchen und dadurch natürlich eine Menge Latenz erzeugen. Google Apps und diesen ganzen Kram. Und hier geht eigentlich der Trend dahin, noch sehr viel mehr in den Kleinen zu verlagern, sodass das Ganze schon mehr eine Application-Delivery ist.
Was eigentlich, wie ich finde, auch auf der Hand liegt. Also Apple ist ja nicht der einzige, die das so machen. Da gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel auch Gears von Google. Die wollen das nicht mehr Google Gears genannt haben, das heißt jetzt einfach nur noch Gears. Was im Augenblick ein Firefox-Plugin ist, aber auch ein Safari-Plugin werden soll. Das ähnliche Funktionalitäten bei Firefox nachrüstet. Zusätzlich zu denen, die Firefox 3 sowieso schon eingebaut haben. Jetzt haben wir Safari 4, von dem du gerade erzählt hast. Der hat ja eigentlich die größte Änderung, die er hat, ist ein neuer Menübefehl. Und damit kann man nämlich sagen, speichere diese Seite als Applikation ab. Was eine relativ hübsche Sache ist.
Save as Web Application steht hier.
Genau. Was exakt in die Richtung geht, die du beschrieben hast. Und wenn man ehrlich ist, was liegt eigentlich näher, als wenn ich irgendwo im Netz eine tolle Applikation habe, ich kann sie ausprobieren, ich kann sie voll testen, ob alles klappt. Und wenn sie mir gefällt, dann sage ich, abfülle es und habe die Applikation komplett gespeichert. Das ist keine Installation mehr. Und wenn es ein Update gibt, dann wird es automatisch nachgeladen, ohne dass ich irgendwas machen muss dafür.
Ja, aber jetzt nochmal die Frage. Warum hat Apple ein so großes Interesse daran, dass sie gleich die Bude kaufen?
Na, weil es wahrscheinlich, also ich würde mal sagen, das liegt auch darin, weil sie mit Mobile Media schon ein bisschen eine größere Kundschaft abdecken. Und das so wichtig ist, dass es da läuft. Dann ist es so billig, die drei Jungs da schnell einzukaufen. Die machen ja dann auch den Job.
Aber warum sollten sie dann das Broadcore so pushen? Dann könnten sie ja glücklich mit ihrem Ding sein.
Die Frage ist, warum sie das denn in der Welt vorstellen. Weil die bräuchten das ja eigentlich gar nicht. Das heißt, dass die Developer das halt benutzen sollen.
Genau.
Weil sie ja auch ein bisschen damit auf den Windows-Markt drängen. Weil die Windows-Leute dann auch anfangen, so eine Sachen zu benutzen. Weil in Safari gibt es ja Windows auch. Warum machen sie das?
Das ist in der Tat ein interessanter Punkt. Das wäre ein Deployment auf anderen Architekturen. Nicht nur Windows, sondern auch Linux.
Also ich halte einen anderen Punkt für...
Aber hilft Ihnen das?
Halt ich erstmal für wichtiger im Vordergrund. Und zwar, wir kennen ja alle das Dashboard. Und das ist ja schon HTML und JavaScript und CSS. Man kann fürs Dashboard einfach ohne sehr, sehr tiefe Erfahrung haben. Also ich meine, bei Objective-C, ich hab vorgestern mit jemandem gesprochen, er meinte, bis man wirklich, vom C++ auf Objective-C ist, ein halbes Jahr braucht man, bis man in den Frameworks drin ist, bis man sich wirklich gut mit der Technologie auskennt und bis man flüssig programmieren kann. Fürs Dashboard...
Da muss man sich immerhin irgendwas... Niemand kann gleich alles, weil man braucht ja nicht alles. Aber ein halbes Jahr braucht man nicht.
Fürs Dashboard könnte ich, mit meiner Erfahrung, die ich als billiger kleiner Web-Entwickler habe, auf der Stelle anfangen, ein Dashboard-Widget zu entwickeln. Ich müsste mir so ein paar... Aber es gibt nur mal unglaublich viele Web-Entwickler da draußen. Weil Webseiten sind in den letzten Jahren wie nix aus dem Boden geschossen. Und jeder hat irgendwann mal eine HTML-Seite gemacht und vielleicht ein bisschen JavaScript dazu gelernt und kann das ein bisschen. Wohingegen irgendwelche Objective-C-Entwickler sind, wie viele gibt es davon auf diesem Planeten? Und man erschliesst sich doch einfach einer unglaublich große Community, wenn man sagt, lass die Leute entwickeln, lass die schöne MacOS-Applikation entwickeln. Und es gibt einige, die in der Richtung aktiv sind. Einige Hersteller, das sind, wie gesagt, Google zum Beispiel, das sind Adobe, Yahoo, hat Initiativen in der Richtung. Natürlich, warum sollte nicht Apple da auch in dem Bereich aktiv sein? Und einfach sagen, zusätzlich zu dem Dashboard, bieten wir in Zukunft auch noch an, dass man damit ganz klassisch in Anführungsstrichen MacOS-Applikationen entwickeln kann.
Und sie wollen natürlich Flash vermeiden.
Was meinst du denn mit MacOS-Applikationen?
Na, genauso wie Java irgendwann mal eine native Sprache auf MacOS war.
Du willst darauf hinaus, dass sie JavaScript als native Sprache unterstützen?
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber dafür bräuchten sie ja nichts Broadcore.
Das kann zum einen ein Zwischenstritt sein, zum zweiten haben wir ja auch noch zwei Telefonien auf dem Tisch rumliegen, das iPhone. Für das das auf jeden Fall auch noch eine interessante Sache ist.
Warum sollten sie noch ein zweites Framework etablieren, neben denen, die sie sowieso haben, mit denen sie wunderbar laufen? Ich finde, das ist jetzt alles noch nicht wirklich eine schlüssige Spekulation.
Man kann auch beides miteinander verknüpfen. Man kann auch sagen, wenn ich Safari offen habe, dann lädt sich Broadcore nicht irgendwelche Bibliotheken aus dem Netz nach, um irgendetwas zu zeichnen, sondern dann nehme ich Quarz und Coco.
Where is the beef? Ich meine, Apple will Geld verdienen. Wie verdienen sie Geld durch Sproutcore? Was trägt Sproutcore zu ihrem Business-Buy, außer dass es die Plattform für ihre Web-Apps für MobileMe sind?
Vielleicht war es das ja auch schon.
Ich könnte mir noch was anderes vorstellen.
Na gut, leg mal los.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dot Mac slash MobileMe und Diensten wie von Google und von Yahoo und so weiter?
Dass MobileMe Geld kostet.
Genau. Apple ist ziemlich die einzige Firma, die im Internet einen Cloud-Service anbietet, für die Leute Geld bezahlen. Was man jetzt mal von Flickr Pro-Account und Xing Pro-Account und so weiter absieht. Aber so subscription-based. Ich zahle 99 Dollar im Jahr, damit mir die Firma bestimmte Dienste aufrecht erhält.
Welche Preise? 79 Euro hatten wir in der letzten Sendung nicht gewusst.
Richtig, 79 Euro. Ich hab mir jetzt dort Mac nochmal hier zum Torusschluss für 49 Euro geschoppt. Das war auf dem Apple Store für den Tag angeboten. Ich ging bei FSC Karlok rüber. Da hat das, glaube ich, eine schöne goldene Nase mit Affiliate Links verdient an dem Tag. Kam dann auch so. Mit dort Mac kann jemand noch nicht so viel anfangen, aber ich schaue jetzt einfach mal für MobileMe, weil das interessiert mich. So, aber MobileMe liefert Applikationen. Wenn sie sozusagen jetzt auch noch so einen App Store aufmachen für MobileMe, also das sozusagen Sprout Core die Plattform ist, für die Entwickler developing können, um dann das bei MobileMe zu hosten. So wie du beim iPhone dir die Applikationen für das iPhone kaufst, könntest du bei MobileMe dir die Applikationen fürs Internet kaufen, die aber automatisch in das Backend von MobileMe mit reingehen. Push, Services, Syncing, Zugriff auf Adressbuchinformation, Zugriff auf diesen ganzen anderen Kram. Wie das OS, das Mac OS X selber solche Funktionalitäten bereitstellt, könnten sie auf Basis von MobileMe vergleichbare Dinge bereitstellen für Web-Applikationen, die dann eben auch unter Windows und auf jedem anderen System auch laufen. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das wirklich glaube, dass sie das tun.
Ich halte es für eine hübsche Idee, aber ich halte es für relativ unwahrscheinlich. Warum? Weil ich hab irgendwann mal das schöne Zitat gelesen, Steve Jobs schafft keine Plattform und wenn dann auch aus Versehen. Das war damals aufs iPhone bezogen. Das Apple legt doch immer sehr viel Wert drauf, geschlossene Bereiche zu liefern. Also zum Beispiel das iPhone, eine abgeschlossene Experience. Das soll nicht irgendwas sein, du kaufst hier irgendwas, damit du nachher Erweiterungen drauf installierst oder sowas, sondern dieses iPhone war, du kaufst hier das Gerät und hast damit alles und das ist super und aber mehr geht auch nicht.
Was ist dann der Mac in dem Zusammenhang?
Und der Mac ist mehr oder weniger so ein Versehen.
Ich glaube auch. Das ist gerade zusammengebrochen schon.
Das ist ein offenes System. Das iPhone ist geschlossen aus ganz anderen Gründen.
Aus welchen?
Na ja, Qualitätssicherung, Batterieproblematik, Sicherheitsproblematik.
Genau, Apple liefert gerne geschlossene Sachen.
Was heißt die liefern gerne geschlossene Sachen? Das Mac OS X ist ein extrem offenes Betriebssystem. Da gibt es die Hälfte schon mal im Source Code und der Rest basiert auf offenen Standards. Ja, und darüber hinaus? Darüber hinaus ist es halt einfach ein proprietäres System.
Nee, aber ich meine, über das Mac OS X hinaus, also ich meine, die iPods gab zwar Spiele von Drittherstellern für, aber nur wenn die über Apple liefern. Es war keine offene Plattform. Ich konnte nie Programme für ein iPod entwickeln.
Weil das ihr Testbed ist. Und das ist übrigens das, was ich vorhin schon angedeutet habe, was auch in dem Podcast über Computerspiele rauskommt. Da geht es um Spiele und der Spielemarkt ist ganz speziell. Und dieses Modell machen alle. Das macht Sony, das macht Microsoft und das macht Nintendo. Nintendo hat das mal erfunden und die anderen machen es ihnen alle nach. Und Apple folgt dort einen ähnlichen Pfad. Und das hat einfach was damit zu tun, dass du diesen Spielemarkt, dadurch, dass du dir deinen eigenen Spielemarkt schützt, deine eigene Plattform, deine Spieleplattform schützt, dadurch, dass du Kontrolle darüber ausübst, wer dafür entwickeln kann. Und beim iPod war ihnen eh klar, dass diese Plattform, die sie da gerade haben, hat keine Zukunft. Die läuft jetzt für zwei, drei Jahre, danach schmeißen sie das wieder weg.
Wir wussten ja auch schon, dass das iPhone kommt.
Ja.
Und das iPhone ist jetzt wieder eine geschlossene Plattform.
Was heißt geschlossene Plattform? Du kannst dafür entwickeln, also es ist offen.
Ich kann dafür entwickeln, wenn ich ganz, ganz lieb bei Apple nachfrage. Ja, natürlich, klar.
So ist das halt.
Wieso?
Damit musst du jetzt einfach mal leben.
Ja, aber das ist eine geschlossene Plattform. Also es ist, wie gesagt, seit dem Mac hat Apple keine offene Plattform mehr geschaffen.
Das ist überhaupt die zweite Plattform, die sie geschaffen haben. Und von daher ist die eine ist halt so und die andere ist halt so. Und die eine ist halt so, weil das eben das Wesen eines Computers ist, dass er offener ist, während das Wesen eines Mobiltelefons, was bestimmte Constraints hat und was ganz nebenbei auch eine Spielplattform ist, andere Constraints hat.
Aber nenn mir, ich meine, jedes Mobiltelefon, was ich mir kaufe, ist offen. Ich kann auf jedem Mobiltelefon Java-Applikationen installieren.
Ja, und auf jedem Scheiß dieser Mobiltelefone fängst du auch auf jedem fucking Flughafen 20 Viren ein. Das ist halt auch einfach Dreck, weil auf jedem dieser Telefone funktioniert nix.
Moment mal, ich will doch gar nicht bestreiten, dass das iPhone ein gutes Telefon ist, ansonsten hat ich es mir nicht gekauft. Aber man muss doch einfach mal festhalten, im Gegensatz zu anderen Mobiltelefonplattformen, oder eigentlich allen, die ich kenne, außer vielleicht dem Sidekick, die sind alle extrem offen. Das ist Google Android, das ist Symbian, Symbian ist, ich kann jetzt anfangen, für Symbian Applikation zu entwickeln.
Da sind wir ja schon beim nächsten Thema. Wir machen jetzt mal die Sproutcore-Geschichte zu. Da haben wir jetzt genug philosophiert.
Also um jetzt mal ganz kurz, nee, warte mal ganz kurz.
Das ist jetzt genau das Thema, das können wir jetzt gerne verfolgen.
Zu Sproutcore wollte ich noch mal zweieinhalb Sätze sagen, also meine Theorie ist, die haben das aufgekauft, um im Web schön Mac-Liker-Applikation zu haben. Punkt.
Aber daran verdienen sie halt nichts.
Und daran verdienen sie halt direkt nicht, sondern nur indirekt darüber, dass das Web ein wenig Mac-Liker wird. Und dass man in diesem Rennen dabei sein will, um die Dominanz über den Browser-Markt und über den HTML-Standard und über das Web.
Da müssen wir erstmal abwarten. Bisher ist ja noch nicht viel gesagt worden. Wir sind ja alle noch im Spekulieren, was mit dem Sproutcore ist. Und vielleicht ist es ja gar nicht so eine große Nummer, wie alle irgendwie denken. Es war ein bisschen mehr gehypt, als da ist, glaube ich.
Das kann schon sein. Aber jetzt bin ich jetzt genau auf den richtigen Punkt gekommen. Zu Simian komme ich gleich. Wir müssen jetzt ja auch nicht so fetzen. Nur ich mag, mich stört einfach dieses Steve Jobs. Was hast du gesagt? Steve Jobs hat irgendwie, was war die Aussage? Hätte ja noch nie offene Systeme gemacht.
Wollte noch nie eine offene Plattform schaffen. Und wenn es passierte, dann aus Versehen.
Diese Aussage krankt einfach an den Begriff, definiere offene Plattform. Was ist heutzutage nicht alles open? Manche Leute verstehen unter open, wenn es nicht alles GPL, offene, freie Software ist, dann ist es nicht offen. Das ist sozusagen der Linux-Maximalansatz. Dann kann man aber auch sagen, wenn irgendwo eine API ist, dann ist es schon geöffnet. Und APIs gibt es auf all diesen Plattformen, über die wir hier gerade reden, ohne Ende.
Ja, aber es ist für mich...
Dass sie dann ein bestimmtes Regulatorium haben, das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Also ich finde...
Also richtig geschlossen ist es nicht, weil man kann ja dafür entwickeln und die meisten Programme werden ja auch durchkommen, dass kein Porn drauf kommt, okay.
Nee, aber erstmal muss ich anfangen. Ich bin von Apples Gnaden abhängig, ob ich für das iPhone Software entwickeln kann oder nicht.
Das würde ich allerdings auch ein bisschen...
Das würde ich als nicht offen bezeichnen. Und wenn Apple darüber entscheidet, ob jetzt mein Programm...
Sie sagen dir ja schon vorher, was du nicht machen darfst.
Sie sagen mir schon vorher, was ich nicht machen darf. Aber auch das ist nach meiner Definition... Also ich meine, was ist, wenn ich jetzt ein Pornoprogramm schreiben möchte, weil wir in Deutschland immer nicht ganz so prüde sind wie die Amerikaner?
Das iPhone hat nicht deine Plattform. Das hat aber nichts mit Apples Gnaden zu tun. Nein, dann ist es überhaupt gar kein Markt für dich. Wieso? Apple ist nicht gezwungen, dir einen Markt für irgendwas bereitzustellen.
Nein, aber es ist keine offene Plattform aufgrund...
Doch, das ist eine offene Plattform, weil du kannst ja dafür entwickeln. Nein, du kannst bloß nicht entwickeln, was du willst.
Genau.
Ja, das ist aber was anderes als offen. Was du meinst, heißt offen ohne irgendwelche Einschränkungen.
Ja, natürlich heißt das offen ohne Einschränkungen.
Ich glaube, ihr könnt euch locker in der Mitte treffen.
Ja, denke ich auch. Kommen wir doch mal auf die aktuellen Bewegungen diesen Markt. Weil du hast ja gesagt, offene Plattform wie Android. Ich meine, Android ist jetzt nochmal irgendwie um ein Jahr verschoben worden. Da kommt einfach nichts bei raus. Ein halbes Jahr, auf nächstes Jahr verschoben worden.
Anfang 2009, Ende 2008.
Ich sag dir, das wird nichts mit Android.
Wieso?
Was soll denn dabei rauskommen?
Hört sich auch so ein bisschen wie eine Microsoft-Nummer, die immer ein Produkt rausbringt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da was bei rauskommt.
Also eine Produktankündigung und dann kommt da mal nichts.
Wer ist denn dahinter?
Google? Alle.
Ja, Google ist dahinter, weil Google da irgendwie seine Services drüber verticken will. Klar ist Google dahinter. Aber nur weil Google seine eigenen Produkte unterstützt, wird es noch lange kein Erfolg. Ich meine, das will man ja wohl mal erwarten, dass Google hinter ihrem eigenen Projekt steht. Und ansonsten, die beiden großen Telefonanbieter in den USA wollen damit nichts zu tun haben. Das sind irgendwie so Platz 3 und Platz 4, unter anderem T-Mobile, die so viele Änderungswünsche haben derzeit, dass das alles nach hinten verschiebt und das Sprint irgendwie auch nicht kriegt, was sie wollen. Also ich glaube, das ist einfach das Problem. Es sind diese Konsortien, die sie da aufgemacht haben. Sie haben gesagt, ja kommt alle zu uns und dann gab es eine lange Liste von Supportern und wir wollen da auch ein bisschen mitmachen. Und die sitzen jetzt auch alle an einem Tisch. Telcos, der Inbegriff von schlechten Dienstleistungen, schlechter Software, unsicheren Systemen, die kommen jetzt an einen Tisch und wollen mit Google Software machen. Ich kann dir nur sagen, meiner Meinung nach, das wird einfach nichts werden. Ich habe noch kein Konsortium gesehen in den letzten 30 Jahren, was irgendwas Brauchbares produziert hat auf dieser Basis.
Also ich bin da bei weitem nicht so pessimistisch. Ich finde das, was Android bisher liefert, so diese ganzen Developer-Previas, die draußen sind und sowas, das ist schon mal relativ hübsch. Und wie nachher die Telefone aussehen, das gucke ich mir später an.
Aber das ist genau, das ist glaube ich der große Fehler, weil beim iPhone weißt du einfach, wie das Telefon ist und dann wird die Software eben auch dafür gemacht. Für was für ein Telefon willst du denn da entwickeln auf diesem Android? Du weißt ja überhaupt nicht, was für Telefone dabei rauskommen. Haben die jetzt irgendwie Tasten oder nicht? Sind die irgendwie Touchscreen oder nicht?
Es wird unterschiedliche Geräte geben.
Haben die GPS oder nicht? Ja, es wird unterschiedliche Geräte geben, so wie es heute schon unterschiedliche Geräte bei Nokia gibt. Und da weiß auch eben keiner, wofür er eigentlich targeten soll. Wie groß ist der Screen? Was sind da für Sensoren drin? Was sind da für Services drin? Hat das Ding GPS oder nicht? Dann hast du 30.000 verschiedene Versionen von jedem Programm, auf jedem Telefon und der Browser muss dann immer genau gucken, hast du jetzt einen E61 oder hast du einen N-Tralala?
Ich glaube, da die meisten Entwickler diese Erfahrung schon seit langer, langer Zeit mit PCs und mit Macs und mit ähnlichen Geräten gemacht haben, werden sie auch auf Mobiltelefonen damit klarkommen.
Das geht auch nicht. Ich meine bei Symbian, sag mal eine Webseite, wo du irgendwie problemlos zehn Programme runterladen kannst, die sich locker auf jedem beliebigen Symbian-Telefon installieren lassen.
Aber bloß weil es bei Symbian nicht geht, heißt das nicht, dass es bei Android auch nicht gehen wird?
Nö, das heißt es nicht. Aber ich sag dir, ich bin da sehr skeptisch, weil bisher habe ich nur eine große Blase gesehen. Google kündigt an, ja wir würden ganz gerne unsere Dienstleistungen als truianisches Pferd bei Telefonherstellern, die keinen Plan haben, wie man Software entwickelt, unterbringen. So, das ist doch im Prinzip die Aussage. Ihr braucht ein Betriebssystem.
Genau, dafür verschenkt man ein Betriebssystem.
Ihr wollt es irgendwie billig haben, weil ihr euch irgendwie nichts anderes leisten könnt und ihr habt auch sowieso keine Ahnung, dann arbeitet doch mit uns zusammen. Das heißt, es ist ein Konsortium von Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben.
Da sind natürlich auch Gerätehersteller noch dabei, die auch durchaus nicht uninteressiert sein dürften.
Genau, die aber auch von Software keine Ahnung haben. Vor allem von User Interface ist keine Ahnung.
Genau, und darum lassen sie sich das Betriebssystem von jemand anderem geben.
Ja, aber Google hat auch keine Ahnung von Geräten und von Computern. Die sind kein Computer-Software-Hersteller, die sind ein Web-Dienstleiter.
Also guck dir Android an, das sieht doch alles nicht schlecht aus. Auf einen entfernten Blick.
Ich guck mir das an, wenn es fertig ist, auf einen entfernten Blick.
Bis dahin hast du nur eine Meinung.
Ja, es gibt ja noch nicht mal ein Telefon. Ich meine, was soll ich mir denn da angucken? Filme im Internet, wo irgendwie langsam ruckelnde 3D-Animationen laufen? Alles, was ich gesehen habe, hat geruckelt. Das hat mich überhaupt nicht überzeugt.
Also alles, was ich auf meinem Internet gestartet habe, hat guckt zu dir.
Jetzt kommt das nächste Konsortium, wurde heute angekündigt. Nokia... Nokia schiebt Panik.
Nokia schiebt Panik? Ja, dazu wollte ich auch noch mal... Okay, leg erst mal los.
Nokia schiebt total Panik. Weil die sehen jetzt ihren Smartphone-Markt natürlich davon schwimmen. Weil sie einfach mal nichts haben. So in den USA sind sie sowieso unter Alpernaliefen. Und in Europa sind sie zwar nominell irgendwie die Nummer 1, aber sie werden das nicht halten können. Also ist die große Frage, was tun sie? Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich ja gedacht, dass sie Symbian wegschmeißen und auf irgendeinen obskuren Linux-Core setzen und dann eben ihre frisch akquirierte Firma, Trolltech, mit dem Coutopia nehmen und darauf ihre Plattform aufbauen. Jetzt haben sie angekündigt, dass sie dieses hybride Symbian Limited System, also diese Firma, wo sie die Hälfte der Anteile besitzen, glaube ich in etwa, wo halt auch noch die ganzen anderen Player mit drin sind, NTT, Docomo und Sony, dass sie das halt komplett jetzt aufkaufen. Das heißt, sie schmeißen 264 Millionen Euro auf diese Firma und kaufen sie auf und wollen sie dann in die Symbian Foundation überführen. Und diese Symbian Foundation soll dann ein Unified Symbian rausbringen. Warum sie das jetzt erst... Das machen keine Ahnung, aber Fakt ist, es gab mindestens drei Symbians, verschiedene Symbians, die überhaupt auf dieser Welt waren, weil jeder da seinen eigenen Scheiß drin hatte, also dieses UiQ von Sony, dann das, was die Japaner da hatten und das, was Nokia hatte.
Ja und es gab ja noch so die ganzen Plattformen, S40, S60, S90 und wie so nicht alle hießen.
Das kommt noch dann dazu.
Ich glaube, das ist der tiefere Grund, warum es immer verschiedene Versionen für verschiedene Symbian-Telefone gab. Aber okay, erzähl erst mal weiter.
Ja, das ist aber so auch schon mal wieder die Problematik. Naja, und dann soll alles gut werden. Das heißt, sie nehmen ein uraltes, vollkommen veraltetes Betriebssystem, was derzeit in drei verschiedene Teile zerschlagen ist. Wollen jetzt erst mal diese drei zusammen nageln, um dann irgendwie was Neues raus machen und Tete-re-té. Darauf hatte ich ja nur noch gewartet. Ein bisschen Open Source haben sie dann auch noch dabei. In der Pressemitteilung heißt es, dass sie selected parts Open Source wollen, nicht welche. Aber sie haben dann auch gleich gesagt, unter welcher Lizenz sie das veröffentlicht wollen, und zwar unter der Eclipse Software License.
Die ich nicht näher kenne.
Da muss ich nämlich auch erst mal nachschlagen. Die Eclipse License ist so eine Art Hybrid aus BSD und GPL. Also auf der einen Seite funktioniert sie so ein bisschen viral wie GPL, wenn du dann damit was machst, dann muss das dann auch unter Eclipse sein und so. Aber es hat halt nicht ganz so harte Vorschriften wie die GPL, was jetzt die Verwendung von Code in Business-Sachen ist. Also man muss nicht unbedingt immer alles veröffentlichen, sondern nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Es ist eine Lizenz, die offensichtlich bei Eclipse, diese Development-Geschichte verwendet wird, die aber so eigentlich nicht gerade besonders viel Bekanntheit hat. Und ich bin mir sicher, das versteht keiner. Also weißt du, BSD-Lizenz, das ist eine klare Aussage. Die ist einfach frei. BSD-Code, kannst du nehmen, kannst du machen, was du willst. Fertig. Das ist die ganze Lizenz. Und bei GPL ist es schon extrem schwierig, im Einzelfall zu entscheiden. Und jetzt kommen sie auch noch mit so einem komischen Hybrid. Außerdem sagen sie nicht, was sie open sourcen wollen. Also ich kann da nur mit dem Kopf schütteln. Was ist los?
Apple hat ja auch eigentlich einen schicken Home Run geleistet, dem sie halt irgendwie ein Telefon irgendwie nehmen. Eigentlich kennen sie sich da gar nicht aus. Aber haben halt irgendwie mal ihr OS X, womit sie sich schon auskennen, da drauf gezaubert und haben jetzt den riesen Vorteil, dass irgendwie Programme kann sie schnell schreiben. Das kannst du wahrscheinlich für Symbian auch nicht mal eben so schnell machen. Und haben sich halt ein Jahr Zeit gelassen, dass erst mal noch keiner Programme schreiben kann. Dann haben sie ihre Apis irgendwie feingetunet und jetzt kann man halt irgendwie programmieren wie ein Weltmeister und haben halt ein schickes OS. Und auch Apple selbst kann halt richtig schick und schnell erweitern. Also, dass das Mail-App irgendwie mal mit Exchange kommt und hier und da 1000 Features hat. Also 1000 übertrieben, aber das ist halt schon schick und das können die anderen alle nicht so schnell. Ich glaube, die müssen auch wesentlich mehr arbeiten, um das alles hinzukriegen.
Also, ich muss ja sagen, Symbian stammt ja nun mal aus einer anderen Zeit als das iPhone oder jetzt Android, diese relativ modernen Plattform.
Ja klar, aber wenn die jetzt mit dem iPhone OS mithalten wollten, was müsste die tun? Die müssten ein neues OS irgendwie aus der Tasche zaubern. Also mit Android versuchen sie es ja, aber ich denke mal, das wird da auch nicht so einfach.
Das ist ja Google und nicht Nokia.
Das ist ja egal, wer es macht, aber es ist halt ein neues OS.
Ja, aber Nokia wird um Himmels willen, die brauchen ihr eigenes Betriebssystem. Ansonsten haben sie es ausgedient.
Deswegen haben sie ja Symbian wahrscheinlich gekauft mit der Intention.
Deswegen haben sie Symbian irgendwann mal... Haben sie mit diesem ganzen Symbian-Zeug irgendwann mal angegessen?
Aber es ist ja auch kein eigenes.
Haben sie irgendwann mal...
Du musstest ja von deinen Mitbewerbern abgrenzen. Aber wenn du in zwei Jahren in den Laden gehst und da liegen lauter Nokia-Telefone und dann fragst du den Verkäufer, wie die funktionieren. Er zeigt dir als klar, dass es Symbian OS ist. Und dann nimmst du das Sony Ericsson daneben und dann sagst du, wie funktioniert das? Und er sagt, er ist auch Symbian OS. Dann entscheidest du ja auch gar nicht mehr nach der schicken Software, die da drauf ist. Weil die ist ja irgendwie gleich, sondern anscheinend nur noch nach der Hardware. Ich weiß nicht, ob das das ist, was die wollen. Aber es ist ja das, was Apple genau nicht macht.
Das ist genau das, was Apple nicht macht.
Das macht Apple auch schon mit den Laptops, also mit ihrer Hardware machen. Die verkaufen sich ja mehr über ihr schickes OS und gar nicht so doll über die Hardware. Obwohl sie immer behaupten, sie sind Hardware-Hersteller.
Und das ist so ein Ding, das kann sich... Apple ist der einzige, den ich kenne, der sich das so leisten kann, diesen Luxus.
Das ist kein Luxus, sondern das ist einfach mal...
Na doch, das ist schon ein Luxus.
Ja, für die, aber ich meine, die haben halt ein schickes OS, weil sie es schon auf dem Rechner haben und sie waren halt so frech, das einfach mal auf dem Telefon zu portieren. Das ist halt der Trick an der Sache.
Nee, also ich meine, Apple... Also ich meine, so Microsoft dominiert den Markt, oder dass Dell so groß werden konnte als relativ kleine Hardware-Klitsche, liegt nur daran, dass sie auf standardisierte Software setzen. Und ich meine, Dell wäre niemals in der Lage gewesen, damals ein eigenes Betriebssystem zu entwickeln und die wären heute pleite, hätten sie probiert, ein eigenes Betriebssystem auf die Beine zu stellen.
Das ist ein Boxenhöcker, ein Systemhersteller.
Aber zum Beispiel...
Genau, sie sind Boxenhöckerer und sind damit groß geworden, dass ich Standard-Komponenten zusammenkauf und sie zusammenklatschen.
Dell ist so ein ganz anderer... Das hat doch wirklich nichts miteinander zu tun. Wir reden jetzt hier von Plattform. Du wolltest ja eine Plattform haben. So, jetzt haben wir wieder ein neues Konsortium. Das Konsortium heißt Symbian Foundation und da sind jetzt auch wieder alle dabei. AT&T und LG Electronics und so weiter und Samsung und Sony. Und Motorola ist übrigens auch noch mit dabei.
Aber es ist ja ganz oft, dass alle wieder aufspringen, weil sie nichts verpassen wollen und nachher springen sie auch genauso.
Genau, natürlich.
Ja, bei Motorola hab ich auch irgendwie im Ohrwahn eigentlich auch bei Android interessiert. Also alle sind jetzt irgendwie bei irgendeiner Party und versuchen alle Hände...
Wenn jemand ganz dringend ein Betriebssystem braucht, dann ist es Motorola auf jeden Fall.
Alle brauchen das. Alle haben das Problem, dass sie kein modernes OS haben und diese Symbian Foundation...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Problem ist.
Natürlich ist das ein Problem.
Wieso?
Na wieso? Wegen erstmal ordentlicher Anwendung dafür programmieren. Hast du schon mal eine benutzbare Symbian Anwendung gesehen? Irgendwas, was auch nur halbwegs den iPhone appeal hat? Da gibt es nichts. Und Security ist ein Problem. Du musst heute auch einfach ein Betriebssystem haben, was auf der Höhe der Zeit ist.
Aber ich glaube, er macht dann ein bisschen Apple zu groß. Weil Apple ist natürlich gut darin, irgendwie zu zeigen, was geht. Und das ist jetzt ein Wachrütteln sozusagen für diese ganze Branche. Aber dass Apple nun massiv, dass irgendjemand massiv an Usern verloren hätte oder sowas, weil das iPhone plötzlich da ist, das ist ja...
26 Prozent des Smartphone-Marktes haben sie.
Nach Apple-Rechnung.
Also ich...
in Deutschland...
In den USA.
In Deutschland wahrscheinlich nicht. Ist auch ein bisschen gesunken.
In den USA, ich hab nicht von weltweit gesprochen. In den USA.
Ist auch ein bisschen gesunken, weil natürlich jetzt alle am Ende kein iPhone mehr gekauft haben, weil alle wussten, dass ja weitest Neue rauskommen. Ist wohl auf knapp unter 20 Prozent gesunken.
Ja, aber ich mein, es ist nicht so, dass Apple hat einfach mal sich ein Viertel eines Marktes geholt. Du kannst nicht behaupten, dass sie für niemanden eine Bedrohung darstellen. Natürlich stellen sie eine Bedrohung dar.
Und zwar von 0 auf 100. Also ich meine, sie sind ja seit einem Jahr dabei.
Eine Firma, die vorher noch nie ein Telefon hergestellt hat.
Also zum einen ist das wahrscheinlich bei den neu verkauften Geräten mit 26 Prozent. Und zum zweiten ist es im Firmenumfeld, glaube ich, wird Apple, müssen sie sich sehr, sehr, sehr viel Mühe geben, also machen sie ja auch, machen sie ja auch, geben sie sich ja extrem viel Mühe, um den Enterprise-Support-Markt anzukommen. Aber das muss weitergehen, um da eine Chance zu haben. Und ich meine, guckt ihr irgendjemand an, der das iPhone in die Hand nimmt? Das sind Leute, die, wenn die einen Blackberry haben, sagen sie, auf meinen Blackberry geht das so und so. Und denen ist das scheißegal, wie die Icons aussehen und ob das alles ein bisschen hübscher ist, solange die nicht ihren, ihre Programme an dem Punkt vorfinden, an dem sie es vorfinden, ist denen das alles relativ scheißegal.
Hast du schon mal einen Blackberry gehabt?
Ich hab noch nie einen Blackberry gehabt, aber ich kenn Leute, die Blackberries haben, ich würd mir niemals einen kaufen.
Also diese Aussage, mit die Programme da vorzufinden, wo ich sie das letzte Mal gefunden habe, das hab ich bei einem Nokia-Telefon, kenn ich dieses Gefühl gar nicht, dass ich überhaupt jemals das Gefühl hatte, irgendwas da wieder zu finden, wo ich es vorher schon mal gefunden hab.
Ich meine, wenn man ein Nokia S60-Gerät bedienen kann, dann kann man auch das nächste bedienen.
Nee. Doch. Nein, ich hab ein S60-Gerät und ich kann auch nicht mal das eine bedienen, weil das nicht bedienbar ist. Ich finde nämlich nicht wieder, also ich finde die Orte nicht wieder.
Okay, Tim.
Du, ich hab da neulich sogar, vor ein paar Tagen, damit ich es leichter finde, hab ich die Google Maps-Applikation aus diesem Unterunterunterordner, in dem es irgendwie drin war, hab ich rausgefunden, wie man da so mit irgendwie Kontextmenü konnte man dann so moveen und so, dann war das auf einem Top-Level. Bis vor zwei Wochen. Und jetzt ist es wieder da, wo es vorher war. Ich hab's nicht angefasst.
Warum hast du dieses Programm, äh, warum hast du dieses Telefon und kein iPhone?
Weil es mir geschenkt wurde und weil ich zu dem Zeitpunkt kein Telefon hatte und eins brauchte. Und deswegen hab ich das noch. Und das iPhone hab ich aus den bekannten Gründen nicht. Die haben wir nun schon tausendmal hier besprochen, die wiederhol ich jetzt nicht.
Ändern sich die Gründe in 15 Tagen?
Ach so, jetzt kommt die große Frage, werde ich mir ein iPhone 3G kaufen? Ich bin sehr am Überlegen, wie ich's mach. Ich wart halt jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen ab, wie ich's...
Du zahlt gerne eins ohne Vertrag.
Ich hätte natürlich gerne eins mit dem Vertrag, den ich schon habe, den würde ich ganz gerne fortsetzen, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich am Ende eine Tischkante beiße und so einen Complete-M-Tarif...
Den für 50.
Den für 50 Euro im Monat schlucken könnte. Hat der schon 5 Gigabyte oder hat der nur 1 Gigabyte? Muss ich jetzt grad nochmal drauf gucken, ne? Wie flat? Naja, so flat ist diese flat ja nicht.
Und das ist genau der Grund, warum...
Also wo es einen in roter Drossel...
Warum Symbian noch eine ganze Weile existieren wird.
Dagegen sagt ja keiner was. Nokia wird nicht von heute auf morgen verschwinden, so wie Microsoft nicht von heute auf morgen verschwinden wird. Aber natürlich tut denen ja auch jeder Prozent weh, den sie nicht mehr haben, weil es ja ein...
Mach doch mal eine Einschätzung, wie viele Applikationen innerhalb des ersten, also innerhalb des Julis noch im App Store verfügbar sein werden.
Innerhalb von Juli noch?
50 bis 100.
500.
Ich glaub auch eher sowas in dem Bereich von 500.
Ich hätte beinahe 1000 gesagt, aber ich sag mal 500.
Das sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie 500 mehr, als man so bei Symbian...
Ich meine, jeder Idiot und sein Bruder will jetzt mit dem iPhone Geld verdienen.
Ja, aber ich...
Wie er schon sagt, weil der Vertrieb hält, du hast da keine Risiko.
Zum ersten, ist es denn, also ich meine, seit wann ist es einfach fürs iPhone zu entwickeln? Also es ist, also wie gesagt, die Aussagen, die ich bis jetzt...
Seit wann, seitdem es das SDK gibt?
Man muss eine neue Programmiersprache lernen. Ich nicht?
Aber guck mal, die Programmiersprache, die gibt es, seitdem es Next-Step, irgendwie, seitdem es die Rechner gibt. Es sind vielleicht nicht viele Leute, aber es sind welche. Und ich meine, Objective-C ist für Leute, die schon programmieren können, echt nicht schwer. Das ist so, als wenn du Java programmieren könntest und dann einer ankommt und sagt, du musst jetzt irgendwie Ruby lernen.
Ich will doch gar nicht sagen, dass es schwer ist.
Sag's aber.
Also ich meine, es ist ein eigenes Framework, man muss sich reinarbeiten. Es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Mac-Entwickler.
Du musst dich in jedes fucking Framework einarbeiten. Du musst dich auch in Symbian einarbeiten, aber in Symbian dauert es halt einfach länger, weil du keine ordentlichen Tools hast.
Ja, aber Symbian gibt es schon unglaublich lange.
Ja, und? Im Gegensatz zu... Ja, das ist doch genau mein Punkt. Symbian gibt es seit Ewigkeiten und nichts ist dabei rausgekommen. Und bis zum Ende dieses Jahres wird sich das iPhone einfach als Plattform für so einen Shitload von vertikalen Applikationen als Plattform empfohlen haben, wo es einfach mal genau nichts gibt auf den anderen Systemen, nicht auf Limo, nicht auf Android und auch nicht auf Symbian, allein schon deshalb, weil die alle erst frühestens in zwei Jahren da sind. Und dann ist es einfach schon zu spät.
Wie viele Symbian-Programmierer gibt es denn? Also wer kann denn Symbian?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also wer kann Symbian? Nur Leute, die halt für Telefone programmieren. Aber für das iPhone kann jeder programmieren, der auch schon in den letzten 15 oder 20 Jahren irgendwie mal für ein Mac oder für eine Next-App-Kiste programmiert hat.
Das sind extrem viele Leute.
Das sind sagenhaft viele Leute.
Mehr als wahrscheinlich irgendwie Leute, die sagen, du musst jetzt fürs Nokia programmieren, dann sagen die, oh, jetzt muss ich mich erstmal mit Symbian beschäftigen, weil hatte ich vorher noch gar nicht.
Vor allem alle Leute, die ich kenne, die für ein Mac programmieren, finden es geil. Und alle Leute, die ich kennengelernt habe, die für Symbian programmieren, sagen, bleib mir mit dem Scheiß vom Leib. Das sind die Aussagen, die ich von diesen Leuten bekomme.
Kinder, also ich meine, worüber diskutieren wir eigentlich gerade?
Wir diskutieren darüber, dass einfach mal das iPhone relativ wenig Competition hat auf diesem Markt.
Es hat eine ganze Menge Competition. Aber bisher hat es keine Schwierigkeiten damit. So würde ich das sagen.
So könnte man es auch sehen.
Also ich finde, es ist durchaus Erfolg zu nennen, dass Apple das hingelegt hat. Wie gesagt, ich mag das Telefon auch. Ich hab selber ein iPhone. Und ich finde es auch schön, dass man dafür jetzt Applikationen entwickeln kann.
Du bist heute so ein bisschen pessimistisch drauf.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht pessimistisch drauf. Aber man macht ja auch nichts. Wir sind auch langsam ans Ende der Geschichte, weil wir nähern uns dem Halbfinale, mein Freund.
Total.
Das ist erst in einer Stunde. Wir gewinnen eh.
Vielleicht so als letztes Thema? Oder habt ihr noch einen anderen Vorschlag?
Wer sind wir?
Ich wollte noch mal was zum Mobile Mi nachtragen. Und zum App Store, wo wir jetzt eh noch mal beim iPhone sind. Aktuelle Zahlen. Man kann wohl Applikationen ausliefern, die maximal 2 GB groß sind. Das finde ich schon ganz schön viel. Das sind so Zahlen, die hochgekommen sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich stimmen, ehrlich zu sein.
Mobile Mi oder was ist das jetzt?
Na wenn du jetzt im App Store eine Applikation hast.
2 GB ist wirklich verdammt viel. Ich hab ja so ein TomTom Gerät und da ist komplett West Europe in einem Gigabyte drin. Plus das Binary und so weiter.
Das heißt zum Beispiel TomTom...
In 2 GB könntest du ganz zentral Europa reinpacken.
2 GB, das mag ich gar nicht glauben. Aber ich hab das so gelesen.
Das ist das, was man über WLAN ausliefern kann, oder?
Das ist dieses iTunes Interface für die Developer. Dann kannst du anklicken, ob deine Anwendung iPod Touch-kompatibel ist oder nicht. Dann hast du auch noch die Möglichkeit, so einen Region-Control zu machen. So ähnlich wie bei DVDs. Das heißt, du kannst Anwendungen auch nur für bestimmte Bereiche der Welt, für bestimmte Märkte anbieten. Warum auch immer, wenn man das machen sollte. Und du kannst halt den Preis bestimmen von kostenlos bis maximal 999 Dollar.
Und der ist dann auch schon weltweit. Haben die so eine Umrechnungstabelle? Dann zeigen sie dir gleich an, was du überall so verdienst. Übrigens noch mal muss ich noch mal ein bisschen zu den Developern vom iPhone. Hast du auch gelesen, wie viele Leute das SDK runtergeladen haben? Unglaublich viele, aber es sind nun 20.000.
Das sind aber auch Leute wie ich, die von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung haben.
Ja klar, die es einfach mal so haben wollen.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber kannst du dir vorstellen, selbst wenn da von 1% übrig bleibt, sind das 250. Das ist nicht wenig.
Wir schreiben dann zwei Programme, dann haben wir schon fünf.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass das iPhone durchaus eine schöne Plattform ist. Und es wird sehr, sehr viele Programme dafür geben. Und sie werden einen unglaublichen Erfolg hinlegen.
Max, du bist ein Ungläubiger.
Und ich muss ja auch mal ein bisschen. Aber es werden am Anfang relativ simple Applikationen bleiben, die nicht sonderlich viel können.
Wobei man muss sagen, Apple hat ja schon einen genialen Schachzug gemacht. Die haben mir gesagt, okay, ab jetzt könnt ihr irgendwie, wir bringen das SDK heute raus und ab heute könnt ihr Programme in den Store packen, dann wäre ja nur der totale Müll gekommen. Sondern das SDK gibt es jetzt seit März oder seit wann?
Genau.
Also sie hatten von März, das ist ja der dritte Monat, also sie hatten vier Monate Zeit, um schicke Programme zu machen. Und da kriegt man schon echt was auf die Reihe in der Zeit. Also ich denke, da werden schon ein paar schicke Perlen dabei sein.
Natürlich werden da ein paar Perlen dabei sein, das bestreite ich auch nicht. Aber es wird dennoch so sein, dass die meisten Programme relativ simpel sein, es werden viele Spiele dabei sein, aber es wird nicht die ausgereifte Lösung sein. Das ist eine Plattform, die ist noch am wachsen, die ist noch am sich entwickeln. Und natürlich ist sie von der Funktionalität her Symbian haushoch überlegen. Das bestreite ich ja keine Sekunde lang.
Ich kenne Symbian noch nicht genug. Vielleicht ist Symbian schon noch ein bisschen ausgedehnt mit den Apis, aber das wird kommen. Aber ich denke mal, auf dem iPhone, du willst ja auch gar nicht so eine riesen Programme wie Photoshop haben, geht ja auch gar nicht, sondern du willst ja schon kleine schicke Tools haben.
Ja, aber auf Symbian ist es zum Beispiel kein Problem, dass ein Programm im Hintergrund läuft. Das führt zu ganz anderen Problemen, ist gar keine Frage.
Okay, das hatten wir auch schon.
Aber solche relativ simplen Sachen sind einfach gegeben.
Lass uns mal zum Ende kommen und ich wollte mal auf die Hörerwünsche hier eingehen, weil ich hatte ja vor der Sendung nochmal gefragt, worauf wir eingehen sollten. Und wenn ich das schon gefragt habe, dann sollte man das natürlich auch tun.
Darf ich bei der Gelegenheit mal sagen, vielen Dank übrigens für das Lob, was immer wieder kommt. Ich sitze ganz unglaublich davor und habe die Befürchtung, dass in Wirklichkeit Tim das nur alles eintippt. Also das, was an Lob kommt, das finde ich immer wieder unglaublich. Für die Sendung finde ich großartig.
Das ist auch immer so lange durchstehen.
Ja, was mich am meisten wundert, ist, dass alle immer es noch länger haben wollen. Aber heute gibt es das nicht, weil gleich ist Halbfinale und deswegen gibt es heute keinen überlangen Podcast. Aber wir sind jetzt auch eh schon wieder weit über der 2-Stunden-Grenze, falls ihr euch gefragt habt, wo wir sind. Hallo, mich würde die Technik hinter MobileMini interessieren, Sproutcore. Haben wir besprochen, denke ich. Brauchen wir nicht weiter zu eingehen. Dann haben wir Erfahrungen mit OS X auf nicht Apple-Hardware. Künstiger Intel-Rechner wäre ja echt verlockend. Na ja, die Clone-Debatte.
Ist halt immer Fummelkram, habe ich schon mal irgendwann gemacht. Muss man halt zum Laufen kriegen und wenn es läuft, dann läuft es eigentlich.
Und beim nächsten Software-Update läuft halt wieder nichts.
Muss man halt wieder an der Bucht nach dem Update dafür suchen und... Die sind auf jeden Fall schon ziemlich fortgeschritten und relativ schnell. Also sie brauchen inzwischen nur noch einen Tag, bis das Update dann auch wieder in Hackintosh-Style am Start hat.
Und es gibt doch eine, ich hab's nur darüber gelesen, es gibt so eine Lösung, dass man so einen kleinen USB-Dongle kaufen soll.
Hab ich auch irgendwo gehört.
Und mit dem kann man dann, man steckt diesen USB-Dongle irgendwie an seinen Intel-Rechner dran, schiebt die Leopard-DVD rein, bootet von der und von da ab ist das Ding wie ein Mac. Sogar inklusive Software-Updates, die man sich runterladen kann.
Mit einem USB-Dongle?
Mit irgendeinem USB-Dongle. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich ist irgendein kleiner Hack auf dem USB-Dongle, den muss man dann kurz starten oder wie auch immer. Oder der USB-Dongle bootet und holt sich den Rest von einer CD. Wahrscheinlich wird es so sein.
Vielleicht ist es auch große Vaporware oder wer weiß der Teufel was.
Ich denke mal, du musst den USB-Dongle booten und der macht das.
Okay, also die Kernfrage können wir beantworten. Habt ihr Erfahrung?
Nein.
So, dann wird hier Komplimente ausgesprochen. Aber dann die Business-Tauglichkeit des iPhones. Ohje, wenn man das jetzt nochmal anfangen würde, dann gehen wir uns ja richtig in die Haare.
Das wird sich davon alleine zeigen mit dem Exchange-Supporter. Werden wir sehen.
Ich kann da kurz, meine Meinung ist, das wird da wo es noch nicht gut ist, schnell besser werden.
Also in den Foren zu den 2.0 Beta sieht man, dass die Leute alle hinter diesem Exchange-Support her sind. Das sind diese, ich weiß nicht, ob das, das sind natürlich nicht die Business-Leute, die in Betas fahren, aber die wollen alle diesen Exchange-Support.
Das sind diese Themenadministratoren.
Und damit kriegst du wahrscheinlich auch die Business-Typen.
Auf jeden Fall, ActiveSync, das ist schonmal so das große Tor mit den ganzen anderen Diensten und den ganzen Pushkram. Ich glaube, also ich glaube sogar, dass das iPhone für Business viel besser geeignet ist als diese Blackberry-Geschichten schlicht und ergreifend, weil man eben dieses Universal-Interface mit dem großen Bildschirm hat. Da kann man einfach Custom-Applications machen. Das ist eigentlich...
Ich weiß nicht, Blackberry ist anscheinend schon dick verbreitet und hat eine dicke Infrastruktur dahinter. Die kriegt man auch nicht so schnell von heute auf morgen weg. Aber der Rest wird sich zeigen, da muss man einfach abwarten. Und die Person, die da fragt, ich meine, ich muss halt wissen, was sie als Server oder als Mail-Server im Hintergrund hat.
Hier ist jetzt noch so ein Plethora von Links zu Artikeln, die ich jetzt leider nicht die Zeit hatte, mir vorher durchzulesen und jetzt auch natürlich nicht nachschlagen kann. Na ja gut, da müssen wir es glaube ich hier bewanden lassen. Ja, dann hier noch ein anderes Gerät. Das hat aber jetzt wirklich gar nichts mit dem Mac zu tun. Dann 10 GB Paket von O2. Wie sieht es aus mit UMTS und HSDPR bei O2? Ach so, mal ein ganz anderes Thema. Kennst du dich aus mit den O2 Datentarifen, Max?
Leider ziemlich überhaupt nicht, außer dass ich gerade vor ein paar Tagen habe ich bei Heise was gelesen zum Thema. Das ist nämlich jetzt seit, da bin ich mir ein Freund schonmal kurz mit angefangen, drüber zu reden, gibt es eine Datenflatrate, wie bei vielen anderen Herstellern auch, für 25 Euro, eine explizite HSDPR-Flatrate.
Ach so, und die haben Sie jetzt auf 10 GB pro Monat hochgeschoben von 5 oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es... Also es ist eine Flat, die irgendwann runter geregelt wird. Ich dachte jetzt bei 5 GB, kann aber sein, dass es auch erst bei 10 ist. Dann wird sie auf unter ISDN, ich glaube auf 56 Kbit runter geregelt.
Auf GPS-Speed dann wahrscheinlich.
Auf 56, also etwas schneller als GPS. Und darüber hinaus, bis man die 5 GB oder diese 10 GB erreicht hat, hat man wohl volle Gefühlenlichkeit.
Die Frage war, wie sieht es aus mit UMTS und HSDP-A? Ich habe ja im Prinzip auch diesen Datentarif. Das macht UMTS, das macht HSDP-A. Das haben wir auch vorhin schon erwähnt. Das wird einfach gehen. Funktioniert eher schlecht, wenn man auf dem Dorf ist. In Berlin funktioniert es allerdings gut. Man hat auch Partial-Roaming mit T-Mobile. Aber das funktioniert nicht so.
Ich will ein neues iPhone haben.
Ja, das nächste neue gibt es erst nächstes Jahr. So, dann Gerüchte über das neue MacBook. Würden ihn interessieren.
Ich kenne keine, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kenne nur die, die kann man aus dem Kaffeesatz lesen. Das ist natürlich vor der Weihnachtszeit, da noch mal ein Update geben wird. Es wird seit Ewigkeiten darüber gerätselt, ob dieses MacBook Pro mal einen neuen Formfaktor kriegt. Das haben wir ja auch schon angesprochen.
Der wird so lange prophezeit, wie der alte Altes?
Ja, also meinetwegen sollen sie da UMTS einbauen. Dann brauche ich mir das vielleicht sogar auch.
Genau, und iSight können sie weglassen. Nee, können sie auch reinmachen.
Ach, hier ist übrigens dieser USB-Dongel auch erwähnt. efix.com Okay, das klicke ich jetzt mal nicht hinterher. Da da da, Latex am Mac habe ich gelesen. Kann ich nichts zu sagen. Ich wollte Latex eh irgendwann mal recherchieren. Das schieben wir einfach mal auf einen späteren Podcast.
Kannst du dann so einen Express-Sendung bearbeiten?
Ja, war da auch schon mal hinterfragt. Ist auch auf meiner Liste, aber viele Dinge sind auf meiner Liste. Und von daher kommen die Dinge immer dann, wenn ich dann auch mal den richtigen Gesprächspartner dafür gefunden habe. Da ich das selber nicht verwende, kann ich da jetzt auch nicht so viel zu sagen. So, aber ein bisschen gewundert habe ich mich über diesen Kommentar. Hier heißt es, was ich nach wie vor nicht hinbekomme und was in meinen Augen noch nicht Mac-like ist, sei Airport. Solange man nur eine Airport-Station hat, ist alles easy, aber ich bekomme es partout nicht hin, mehrere Airports in dasselbe Netz zu hängen. Möchte die Airport Express als DSL-Router einsetzen und die Airport Extreme als Print- und HD-Point nutzen?
Was heißt denn dasselbe Netz? Da gibt man die gleiche SSID und dann rohmt man zwischen denen und dann ist fertig, oder nicht?
So sehe ich das eigentlich auch.
Wenn die beiden einzeln mit Ethernet am gleichen Netz dranhängen, wenn die eine nur so eine, wie sagt man, Forwarding-Station der anderen sein soll, also die eine gar nicht nur per Luft an der anderen dran ist, über WLAN halt, dann muss man die irgendwie koppeln. Da habe ich leider keine Erfahrung, weil ich habe halt nur eine Station zu Hause.
Du meinst jetzt, wenn die über WLAN miteinander verbunden sein sollen?
Genau, wenn die zweite Station selber gar nicht am Netz per Ethernet dran ist.
Also genau, wenn man Ethernet hat und beide haben Ethernet, dann ist es eigentlich kein Problem. Dann nimmt man denselben Netznamen und dann hat man automatisch Roaming. Die Base Stations verständigen sich untereinander. Ich finde das durchaus Mac-like, um ehrlich zu sein. Das andere ist WDS. Damit habe ich mal ein bisschen rumgespielt. Das hat so seine Pitfalls. Was wirklich knifflig bis unmöglich ist, ist WDS mit anderen Geräten zu machen. Was aber vor allem daran liegt, dass dieser WDS-Standard von vielen Herstellern sehr persönlich ausgelegt wird und damit der Interoperabilität nicht weit her ist. Aber wenn man jetzt nur so eine Airport Express nimmt, zum Beispiel, also ich mache das immer ganz gerne auf Reisen, habe ich häufig zwei Airport Express dabei, damit ich in der Lage bin, irgendwo wo es Netz gibt, das dahin, wo ich bin, zu verlängern. Dann mache ich das so, dass ich die eine Airport Express da ranstecke, wo es das Netz gibt, also auch per Internet sozusagen, und mache da halt ein eigenes WLAN auf mit WDS, dann ist das sozusagen der Primary Port von diesem Primary Host, jetzt die Terminologie gerade nicht ganz parat, Master, irgendwas, und die andere bucht sich dann halt da ein und verlängert das halt weiter. Dann hast du dann halt auch oben nochmal WLAN, sozusagen, aber gebrückt über diese beiden Stationen. Das heißt, ich hab WLAN da, wo ich es brauche, man hat ja häufig dieses Ding, so WLAN reicht nicht ran, und so kannst du halt sowas damit auch verlängern. Aber es ist immer sehr knifflig, je nachdem, hast du irgendwie Ethernet oder ist es nur WLAN, was du verlängern musst.
Aber gab es dann nicht mal so ein Deployment oder so ein Design-Tool von Apple für gerade Unis und so, die mehrere Stationen haben? Oder zumindest so ein Dokument, auf wie man das zu gefallen hat.
Ja, ein Dokument gibt es. Es gibt da so ein PDF, wo irgendwie drin steht, wie man seine Netze aufbauen kann. Da ist auch diese ganze WDS-Geschichte beschrieben. Das müssen wir noch mal raussuchen.
Ich hab übrigens noch eine Frage an unsere Zuhörer. Und zwar ganz simpel, ich muss mal kurz abweichen. Beim Login-Screen von US-10 gibt es ja entweder, dass beide Input-Fields da sind, und zwar Name und Passwort. Und dann gibt es noch den Modus, dass da nur so ein Icon ist und man draufklickt und dann kann man nur noch das Passwort eingeben. So und es gibt auch diesen Trick, dass man in seinem Namen, also da wo der Name eingetragen wird, dass man dort irgendwie größer Zeichen Konsole eintippt und man dann in so einen Terminal-Modus kommt. Ich weiß nicht, wenn das noch nicht alle höhere kennen. Jedenfalls hätte ich gerne den Trick, wie ich von dem Modus, wo das Icon da ist und man nur noch das Passwort eingeben kann, da gibt es, habe ich früher mal gelesen, ich finde es nur nicht mehr wieder, gibt es irgendeinen Tastenkürzel, wie man zu diesen beiden Input-Fields wieder zurückkommt, dass man beides eingeben kann. Dass man zum Beispiel auch noch so einen Root-User sich einloggen kann, weil es würde ja normalerweise nicht gehen, weil der ist immer nicht mit aufgelistet. Und da gibt es so eine Tastenkombination für uns. Die hätte ich gerne, wenn irgendein User die noch weiß, dann soll er die mal posten.
Was es gibt ist, und ich glaube, das ist so ein Hidden-Pref, du kannst so ein Others mit einblenden. Das ist keine Tastenkombination, sondern hast du halt jeden User, den es gibt, und dann gibt es noch einen Eintrag Other. Und wenn du den anklickst, dann kommt halt der normale Username, Passwort.
Irgendwie sowas hätte ich gerne.
Das geht mit dem schönen PrefPlan Secrets.
Genau, dass man sowieso mal pluggen sollte.
Ja, und das hat alle Versteher verstehern.
Und das hat unglaublich viele solcher Systeme.
Du hast es schon einfach mit drin, weil du drückst immer so eine Tastenkombination und dann kommen einfach wieder beide Input-Fields und dann kann man da wieder machen, was man will.
Ah, hier, guck, kann man nicht ausschließen. Bei Secrets unter Systems gibt es hier den Show Asas in Login-Window. Da machst du Checkbox dran und nach dem nächsten Neustart hast du es.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob wir Secrets schon mal erwähnt haben. Das ist dieses schöne Kontrollfeld.
Sowas wie Tinkertool oder wie?
Ja, aber das hat einen Repository auf dem Server. Das heißt, du kannst das Ding halt immer wieder updaten mit der aktuellen Liste von known hidden-preps.
Ok, das Binary bleibt das Gleiche, weil es halt generisch und dann holt sie dir da die...
Du hast es updaten und dann zieht er sich das vom Server. In den letzten Wochen und Monaten hatten sie häufiger mal Hostdown. Das scheint da ein Problem zu geben mit dem Erfolg, aber...
Weil es sind nämlich auch nur Property-Lists, die da geändert werden. Genau, genau.
Und die machen halt... Secrets bietet halt Sachen nur an, die halt das Default-System, keine anderen Hacks und nur was sie wirklich...
Keine Falschereien, ja, so hätte ich es gerne. Weil zur Not kann man auch mal die Property-Lists löschen, dann fängt man nämlich frisch von vorne an.
Genau, und das ist Secrets. Also wenn was Neues entdeckt wird, dann taucht das da in der Regel relativ schnell auf. Das ist wirklich ziemlich hübsch. Also ich weiß nicht ganz genau hier bei der Airport-Frage, was er so mit Mac-Lag-Wahntchen und anderen Kommentatoren meint, auch so, ob er sich da so ein grafisches Design-Tool da vorstellt. Das wäre in der Tat eigentlich mal gar nicht so schlecht, dass es so ein Programm gibt, wo man wirklich sagen kann...
Mir war so, als wenn es für Unis mal sowas gegeben hätte.
Ich weiß es nicht.
So wie er das aktuelle Airport-Admin-Utility auch jetzt mehrere Stationen auf einmal verwalten kann und so gab es da auch noch irgendwie was anderes.
So, wir müssen zum Ende kommen. Du möchtest ja noch Fußball gucken irgendwo, ne? Ich schon, aber ich bleib ja hier. Aber er will noch irgendwo hingehen.
Hast du dein Fernseher noch?
Na, ich hab jetzt hier Fernsehen über USB-Stick, mir dieses iTV...
Ich meine, dein Röhren-TV wolltest du doch loswerden.
Ja, noch hab ich ihn. Heute gibt es noch mal auf Röhre. Dem lest dann im Quadrat.
Fußball auf Röhre.
Ja, dann war hier noch die Frage, ok, das mit diesem Kopieren-Ersetzen im Finder. Angenommen, ich möchte Verzeichnis AAA mit sehr vielen weiteren Unterverzeichnissen auf ein USB-Laufwerk verschieben. Der Kopiervorgang bricht etwa nach der Hälfte des Verschiebevorgangs ab. Wenn ich nun im Finder das Verzeichnis AAA erneut auswähle und möchte den Rest verschieben, fragt mich der Finder, ob er die vorhandenen Dateien ersetzen soll. Ja, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, erregt er sich darüber auf, dass es kein Continue- und kein Append-Modus gibt.
Das Problem ist, wenn er den äußeren Ordner nimmt, wo die anderen Ordner drin sind, und den neu rüberschiebt, dann ersetzt er komplett den Äußeren. Also die Frage ist, die dann da kommt. Also er muss einfach den Inhalt von diesem Ordner nehmen, da reinschmeißen. Und dann muss er, der Gezerasen Replace und all, da kann er sozusagen, alles, was schon da ist, soll er dann nicht mehr ersetzen.
Ja, das ist aber gefährlich.
Aber wenn da drin auch wieder Ordner drin sind, dann hast du das gleiche Problem, dann kann da trotzdem einer nicht vollständig sein.
Also es wäre schon ganz schick, wenn er auch, es würde schon manchmal reichen, wenn er eine Datei nicht kopieren kann, wenn er einfach die restlichen Kopiervorgänge im Hintergrund fortsetzt und mir im Nachhinein mitteilt, die eine Datei könnte ich aber nicht kopieren.
Der Feiner muss sterben.
Der Feiner muss sowieso sterben. Der Feiner muss schon immer sterben.
Das geht mit Apfel, Alt, Escape. Und dann gibt's hier, ach, das heißt auf Deutsch nicht Kill.
Max, wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit.
Ich wollte noch Fußball gucken.
Also, mit anderen Worten, die Antwort ist, warum ist das so, wie es ist? Damit es immer funktioniert. Und bei so einem komischen Append-Modus mit Tralala, mit Hidden Files und so weiter, das ist total deadly. Und ich finde das ganz okay, wie es so ist. Und man sollte vielleicht ein USB-Laufwerk dann einfach mal dafür sorgen, dass das Kabel nicht abgeht. Oder wenn da noch andere Hardware-Probleme liegen, ist das das vielleichtste Ding. So, dann wird noch gefragt, keine Ahnung, ob ihr in dem Thema fit seid, aber ich finde meine Durchleuchtung der USX-Geschichte furchtbar interessant. Da habe ich mir notiert, das wollen wir jetzt hier nicht durch-exerzieren.
Aber haben wir doch gut durchleuchtet, oder nicht?
Dir wird immer mal wieder was dazu fallen, aber ich verweise hier einfach mal auf Chaos Radio Folgen. Und zwar Chaos Radio 126 und Chaos Radio 60. 60 ist schon ein bisschen länger her. Das ist so ein Podcast zum Zeitpunkt, als Apple gerade Next gekauft hat.
Ja, da war ich ja auch noch mit dabei.
Da warst du glaube ich auch mit dabei.
Ja, man hört mich zweimal, ich hab mich in Grund und Boden gequatscht.
Ja, weil ich so eine Plappertasche bin. Komm mir nicht so! Und Chaos Radio 126 ist so eine mäßige Sendung. Das war die erste Sendung, wo Chaos Radio auch zwei Stunden geschrumpft ist. Und Pablo und ich, wir haben irgendwie eine Nacht vorher, also nicht mal einen Tag vorher, sondern eine Nacht vorher ein Notprogramm dieses Thema hochgezogen. Und eigentlich wollten wir halt viel über Mac OS X erzählen, aber vor allem haben wir da viel über die Geschichte erzählt, mit anderen Worten. Diese Frage kann mit Chaos Radio 126 beantwortet werden. Ja, haben wir da noch irgendwas? Hier gibt es dann viele Antworten zu den Fragen, die da gestellt sind. Schön, ihr diskutiert auch untereinander, so gehört sich das.
Genau.
Wie wird man das UMTS auf dem MacBook nutzen können, haben wir besprochen. Ach so, hier eine Frage an Tim und die ist nicht auf Topic, weil Dennis auf dem Bild einen Burn Venture Capital Burn Shirt an hat. Was ist denn mit Interhemd? Ach so. Na ja, Interhemd...
Was ist denn Interhemd?
Interhemd? Na, ich hab ja mal das erste Nerd-Shirt-Modelabel gegründet, lang ist's her.
Okay.
Interhemd.
Kannst du nicht?
Nein.
Das gerade nicht.
Ja, ich trag auch gerade kein Interhemd. Na ja, aber diese ganzen CCC-Shirts und so weiter. Diese ganzen...
Sie können ihren Rechner jetzt wegwerfen.
Sie können ihren Computer jetzt wegwerfen.
Und Exchange Microsoft, das fand ich immer schick.
Also...
Dennis, warum trägst du ein Microsoft-Shirt?
Ich...
Nee, liess mal richtig.
Ich hab halt mal Interhemd gestartet, weil es gab einfach keine coolen Shirts. So, dann hab ich das irgendwie gemacht. Später kamen dann halt diese ganzen Zink-Nerds und wie sie alle heißen auch in den USA auf.
Da kann ich ja mal kurz noch mal ganz kurz zwischendurch werden. Bei Spreeblick gibt es jetzt ein wunderbares unter 140 Zeichen, fand ich dich besser-Shirt im Shop.
Für Twitter-Freunde?
Von mir.
Unter 140 Zeichen fand ich dich besser? Worauf spielt das an?
Auf Twitter.
Da gehen nur 140 Zeichen? Wollten sie nochmal SMS unterbieten? Oder was?
Aber Twitter hatten wir jetzt schon als Thema. Jetzt ging es gerade um Shirts.
Ich glaube, wir waren auch gerade fertig.
Ja, also Interhemd gibt es nicht, weil ich einfach andere Sorgen habe und T-Shirts ist echt aufwendig und so. Ich habe schon immer wieder mit dem Gedanken gespielt, das wieder aufleben zu lassen, aber dabei ist es dann auch immer wieder.
Macht selber Shirts, das geht mit Spread Shirts, echt schön einfach.
So, dann würde Ihnen Herr Weißkraut gerne wissen, was die absoluten Lieblings-Apps von Max, Dennis und Tim sind. Und wie sich Softwareentwicklung zwischen Mac, Windows und Linux unterscheidet. Oh, das führt zu weit, aber das können wir gerne...
Also Lieblings-Apps können wir eine schöne Sendung aufgreifen. Also ein schönes Thema für eine...
Mein Lieblings-App?
Ja.
Was ich andauernd häufig benutze, was sozusagen immer an ist?
Ein Andermal.
Achso.
Ja, nö, warte mal. Nur eine Applikation sagen oder zwei oder drei. Ich kann mal die sagen, die bei mir immer laufen. Also ohne die mein Computer...
Aber ganz schnell, ohne Begründung.
Ohne Begründung?
Ja, sonst dauert es zu lange.
Omni-Outliner, Text-Mate, NetNews-Wire, Mail?
Ja, ich hab Safari, Mail, Terminal, Adium, Colloquy, iTunes.
Stimmt.
Was hab ich hier noch Schönes? Ich hab Mail, NetNews... Immer offen.
Letzter Zeit öfter.
Mail, NetNews-Wire, Safari, Firefox, Adium, iTerm statt dem Terminal, wie edit eigentlich immer, und ein FTP Client, in meinem Fall Jummy FTP. Und das war es mit dem ganz immer offen.
Na ja, vergleichbar, ne?
Eigentlich schon relativ vergleichbar. Lieblingsprogramm wäre noch mal ein Thema für sich.
Das können wir einfach mal in einer Sendung an den Mittelpunkt stellen, dann kann jeder genau erzählen, warum das so ist, wie es ist.
Ich bin da sehr minimalistisch in meinem Programm.
Schluss für heute mal. Ich denke, das war's.
Und nicht in die Kommentare schreiben, wie das Spiel ausgegangen ist. Ich möchte das noch gucken.
Diese Sendung ist sowieso erst danach.
Es ist ein Viertel von neun, oder?
Das Spiel. Es ist ein Viertel von neun, fängt es an, ja.
Ja, ich weiß ja noch nicht, ich weiß ja davon nichts.
Nee, nee, das ist schon vorbei.
Nee, vorbei ist es nicht, das weiß ich, aber Viertel von neun war's. Nö, dann ist es Feierabend.
Ist noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Wir sagen Tschüss. Bis bald. Das hast du jetzt nicht gesagt denn, oder?
Oh, das muss ich überbieten. Adiöle.
Das können wir jetzt in jeder Sendung überbieten. Tschö mit ö.
Ja, das Niveau sinkt, die Stimmung steigt.
Zuerst? Nein, das war doch, als du auf den Record geklickt hast.